peu
c'est le livre de jane milner éditions
la découverte qui nous a donné l'idée de
consacrer à bernard tapie notre premier
destroy mensuel tapis mythe des années
80 titres jeanne et qu'elle me tu finis
les 70 ça va les babas l'époque alors et
augagneur vivent les meilleurs exit les
hippies ou elle comme les youpi bravo
tapis oublier manufrance oublier car
assistance désormais tapie est au sommet
l'un faire des châteaux de l'ex-empereur
bokassa n'est pas rentré dans l'histoire
dieu a créé l'homme pour monter des
entreprises l'avenir appartient à tapis
et à tous ceux qui écoutent ses conseils
maintenant les vainqueurs vous at il à
de marché pour présenter plus de 60 % de
ce marché
je veux vraiment que ça doit sûrement
figure
on ne peut plus concevoir la visite
l'abordage d'un vendeur de chez vous
sans sentir il est le représentant de la
firme des leaders dans son vagin qui
aime sa femme a mis les pouces d'infamie
terraillon bernard hinault madame
grecque et sa grande idée pour supprimer
les pauvres c'est tout le monde soit
riche 1985 sauve qui peut c'est à pie
qui chante en trois mois les emplois
premier aux chômeurs sont divisés par
cinq
tapie est il vraiment bernard est votre
position par rapport à tous les gens qui
tapissent est un aventurier style dallas
où tous les coups sont bons ça va être
beaucoup mais si tous les coups étaient
bons depuis le temps qu'on essaie de les
trouver on les aurait déjà trouvé je
crois et ariane otaniens quelle
opposition par rapport à tout ce qui
vous conteste en disant tu as piste un
aventurier à la dallas pour tous les
moyens sont permis et c'est ce qui me
conteste med
en fait il met pas ce qu'il me donne
savoir communiquer c'est bien savoir
quoi dire c'est mieux sinon on se prend
les pieds dans le tapis
s'il y avait des choses contestable
depuis le temps qu'on fait du bruit
autour savez tout les clochettes sonne
ça se saurait on va se battre je vous
présentais les gens en ont ras le bol
et jean louis roquet notre structure pas
de souci avec moi
brouillet responsables de tf1 concernant
sinon tu tout comme une triste ses
ambitions tf1 1986
c'est l'apothéose mais la fin de la
montée c'est aussi le début de la
descente et la trop vouloir se montrer
on finit par le pouvoir plus rien cacher
et derrière on seulement 6,9 et et ça
veut dire voilà on est vraiment et pas
seulement des fonds table et parce que
l'on est rude
question look les problèmes avec la
famille ben el cata ça la fout mal
il est trop tard tapie dit dans la pub
qu'il marche à la vendeur mais vendeurs
avec tapis ça marche pas si bien que ça
t1 sans bien sûr ça peut rapporter gros
mais tapis vert ne possèdent qu'un point
66% du capital du nord de jouer dans la
cour des grands pas facile d'être invité
au bal du gouverneur faute d'épouser sa
série tapis décide d'enlever la ville
après le tapis rouge sur la canebière
c'est le carton jaune bodmer amenant
larbi me dis tiens j'avais pas lu la
même photo que je gère bien et il a
répondu bah si moi je suis sûr d'avoir
raison
une image depuis dans notre président
qui sautent sont en train d'être mais
non mais j'ai pas sauté je vous jure que
le jour où je vais sauter son habitude
ça serait que j'aurai les plombs qu'on
saute et moi même et puis je le ferais
dg ce personnage
succéder à gastounet c'était le pari de
l'homme de faire passer des valeurs en
bourse son retour des malheurs
c'était son ambition pour les années 90
mais 88 élections législatives dans la
cité phocéenne comme on dit au ballon
faute de dévorer tous plus l'ogre le pen
dans la huitième
le manager de bernard hinault devra se
contenter de jouer les poulies nord dans
la sixième n'est pas michael jackson qui
veut mon pote
[Musique]
à l'entrée c'est dehors que c'est dur et
d'orge c'est dur en fait je pense que
c'est bien qu'on soit tous là je pense
que c'est un bon signe côté un peu de
michael jackson en fait ça je sais pas
je ne sais pas faire ce qu'il sait faire
je suis pas sûr qu'ils sachent faire ce
que ses cernes oculaire monde ne pousse
un pipe record en record de retard dans
sa traversée de l'atlantique et il ne
barre pas mieux le feu c'est là que la
route à l'extrême droite
mais le vrai drame de tapis yeux c'est
de ne pas avoir été tapie y faute d'être
une rock star il aura tout fait pour
être une vedette même gagné des
milliards
[Musique]
pourquoi je être un artiste est tombé
pile sol kleebach mon pote décidément
t'es pas vraiment synchro nanar
[Musique]
alors va-t-il devenir un héros de série
sur tf1 va t-il se relancer dans la
politique
va-t-il reprendre lors m à nouveau tout
le monde en parle
voici mes énormes et bernard tapie qui
sont que mensonges
citation x men qui reste le parcours 1 2
ne sais quoi comme fait pourtant ou de
tonnes bernard tapie bonsoir bonsoir
vous connaissez laurent baffie et
comment elle avait un truc pour toi vous
êtes vus à à la première de canal j'ai
fait un cadeau
ouais je parlais tout à l'heure dans la
loge et ramenez pas celle d'origine
parce que moi je l'avais signer et faire
et celle d'origine je les gardais voilà
vous êtes libéré de prison
voilà c'est une carte c'est une carte du
monopoly et n'auront vinci avait offert
en verlan sa fille à l'école laurent le
petit chat canal et bernard bonsoir donc
vouthon telle aventure sur une chaîne
une chaîne du câble s'appelle rtl 9 ans
l'émission s'appelle rien à cacher c'est
le dimanche à 19h20 donc est venu
l'interviewer une personnalité tous les
dimanches mais rtl9
vous êtes sûr bernard tapie que c'est
pas pour des raisons fiscales que vous
et non parce que c'est une société
française avant parce qu'on le siège est
à paris bon j'ai pas domicilié en
belgique en ce moment non j'aurais bien
voulu mais parce qu'il paraît que vous
recevez du courrier ordinaire si c'est
vrai puisque l'on respire la vérité 1 3
rond point de l'étoile à ixelles c'est
dans la banlieue de bruxelles chez le
bourgmestre qui s'appelle yves de jonghe
d'ardoye des retraites un vicomte
il paraît que vous recevez du courrier
chez lui non c'est parce que j'ai été
député européen moins longtemps et quand
on est député européen on habite au
moins trois jours par semaine en
belgique à dakar et donc j'habitais là
bas et c'est ce qui fait que j'ai une
adresse belge et que j'ai un lieu de
résidence belle je me suis pas résident
dans la mesure où poids ce statut vous
le savez le fisc impôts baii mais oui on
est plus de sens eu plus de 160 jours
par an voilà donc moi dans ma peau vers
dati voulait des avoirs à l'étranger
parce que tout le monde l'an va être mon
désir tout voir est-ce que tapie oui il
aurait pas à l'étranger des comptes
mashhad
j'en ai pas mais bien sûr c'est pas
seulement j'en ai pas sérieusement ils
ont tellement cherché mais tellement
tellement tellement parce que ça leur
faisait plaisir quand il ya un truc que
je comprends pas vous une plein d'ennuis
et vous avez toujours votre hôtel
particulier le dessin terre non non non
j'ai c'est une occupation à la fois
partiel est momentanée ouais en fait la
famille de la pinatelle particulier à la
maison perçu pour arriver à est riche
quand tu pars de canal c'est long il ya
un temps de réponse très long et
pourrait pauvres quand on ne croit
riches c'est long aussi mes cd mangez
[Applaudissements]
les riches des pauvres à la hâte en je
suis probablement dans un statut fiscal
unique au monde
unique au monde parce que aujourd'hui
j'ai décrire la situation quand je gagne
1000 francs
ouais je le dis elle a déjà joué avant
qui parle pognon c'est très malin de
mettre plus de la des pierres s'est dit
assez dégueulasse
parce que c'est pas là mais pierre
ducout ses classeurs teresa alors tu te
souviens pas tu te souviens pas que on
va parler en anciens francs pour battre
pendant servant même pour ma mère alors
sans sac
bon les impôts normal près de 50% ça
fait cinquante comme jeu sur liquidation
des biens ils prennent 30 puisque je
donne un tiers d'annulations
donc je gagne son franc j'ai cinquante
francs qui va officier crayon et 4 et 30
francs non mais les juifs
hélas la france irait son fils alban
tampico seulement maintenant comme les
dois à mon fils et une amende en 95
parce que j'ai été assez qu'on mette
m'en veux être mon bateau sous pavillon
français a tendance aussi prôné les vins
français rien ventura c'est vachement
mieux il faut que tous les français qui
écoute là ils se rendent compte qu'on
est un pays de malades quand je gagne
1000 maintenant les doigts me prennent
les bills 4 0 ban a d'abord
et après je paye 500 ouais office et 300
à fait d'accord je suis le seul mec au
monde
chaque fois je gagne un peu d'argent je
dois beaucoup d'argent puisque je vois
c'est vrai les vins qu'ils me prennent
lance un appel alors attend non mais
attends parce qu'à la limite le cumul
des différentes coiffer que tout le
monde à un moment donné vous en savez
quelque chose peut avoir affaire à eux
mais ce qui est monstrueux et asie dans
cette île et il le sait le sait le 7
août à valence et à 5 ans j'ai eu un
contrôle qui se finit vachement bien bon
gars qui connaissaient déjà et je
connaissais strauss kahn j'ai filé des
cassettes pornos il les a pas regardés
sociale en même temps là là où c'est pas
là où c'est pas bien et là où je pense
que je vais me fâcher et pour de vrai
attention c'est que quand on syndiqué es
mon avocat arrive et dit aux douanes
m'attendais c'est une bête de 95 il ya
donc l'argent cash la halle à nantes
vous pouvez vous faire payer cash
ça les a pas intéressé autrement dit là
c'est plus dans le sens de l'intérêt du
public puisque l'intérêt du public c'est
toucher l'argent
ouais là plutôt que de toucher les 5
millions d'âmes en cash ils préfèrent
aller m'emmerder sur mes cachets de rtl9
ou et de vol au-dessus d'un nid de
coucou de comédien alors pourquoi on
vous a saisi effectivement vos salaires
de comédiens avocat chez le comédien
survol au dessus d'un nid de coucou vos
cachets d'animateur sur la haine c'est
est-ce que c'est l'histoire du fossé a
cédé 6 millions de francs que vous devez
pour le e55 ouais pourquoi je voulais me
sous pavillon français ou le mettre sous
pavillon panaméen
non parce que j'étais assez peu prudent
est ce qu'on fait je crois que c'est pas
de la volonté de s'extraire à l'impôt
que les gens mettent leur bateau sous un
pavillon étranger
c'est parce que les normes de la marine
marchande français sont devenus
tellement contraignantes qu'elles sont
pratiquement plus applicable ce plan
judiciaire année tous bernard pasquet
toujours un procès en cours pour
banqueroute et détournements d'actifs
qui bloque en fait la procédure c'est
votre procédure vous d'attac contre le
crédit lyonnais
c'est qu'en fait vous avez déclenché une
action contre le crédit lyonnais vous
pouvez gagner beaucoup d'argent non
parce que c'est sur la vente d'adidas
bah si on gagne là vous êtes de nouveau
très très riche je vais récupérer ce
qu'on m'a pris ouais
fait beaucoup d'argent ça peut faire
beaucoup en fait ce que vous dites c'est
que l'histoire d'adidas vous que
racontez nous la faire parce que c'est
intéressant comment vous vous êtes fait
spolier dans cette histoire d'adidas
nommé se faire spolier dans le monde des
affaires
il n'y a pas de quoi se faire plaindre
il m'est arrivé de rouler dans la farine
et de me faire rouler dans la farine
c'est une des règles du monde des
affaires à condition que résident les
règles ce qui est pas tolérable c'est
quand vous donnez un mandat de vente un
banquier pour vendre un de vos actifs
qui vous prétend l'avoir vendu 2
milliards à caen fait le même jour il a
revendu quatre et demi voilà centenaire
dire on dit ça c'est pas bien pourquoi
le faire alors si c'est une banque
mineurs etc sans importance on peut se
dire bon cd gogniat mais dès lors que
c'est une grande banque nationalisée
avec à la tête des gens importants et
compétents on est en droit de dire c'est
un abus ce serait aux états unis la
vente est nulle
ah ouais bon cinq frères quasi la
retraite annuelle aujourd'hui serait
adidas reviens chez moi ça vaut 35
milliards us
c'est bien je vous donne un autre
chiffre marquant ils m'ont vendu les
actions d'adidas de tf1 100 millions 1,4
milliard rome donc c'est pour vous dire
que j'ai et le tribunal actuellement
depuis cinq ans on cherche à savoir si
on va le juger ou si on va pas le juger
c'est les lenteurs des procédures et
alors tu es plus vite pour me coller en
taule pour un match de football
oui il y en a qui viennent le faire là
bon alors donc la pilule c'est un bon
vol au-dessus d'un nid de coucou est en
tournée rtl9 belle dimanche cette
démarche là à 19h 20h sur rtl9 gravité
c'est qu'ils s'auto me sens tellement
bien alors et puis attendez la up
attention il ya l'om voilà lycées bigdil
ah [ __ ] là ça fait mal big deal
alors là moi je crois qu'on est bon
pardon d'abord on va faire un petit
flashback onva pour vous c'était le
début de la fin non c'était le déclic
dans votre vie c'était le début de
lafarge a été le prétexte le prétexte
voilà on vous le début il ya belle
lurette le phallus et quand je fais 12 %
aux européennes près faux
après bon après faut arrêter ça ça
aurait pu être de la cam dans mon coffre
aurait pu être n'importe quoi mba et il
y avait mellick
la semaine dernière il est génial on l'a
raconté son livre j'ai pas eu le temps
de ville
mais il est génial parce qu' ils
racontent une histoire apparemment
toujours la même et il a je crois fini
par y croire
alors je vais simplement dire à mon ami
mais vic que j'adore parce que c'est
vraiment un mec a du cac et fidèle que
si j'avais été quoi que ce soit
quoi que ce soit dans la construction de
son faux témoignage
j'aurais été un peu inquiété pour faux
témoignage ou complicité de faux
témoignages bien
alors maintenant d'un tapis sérieusement
vous êtes juridiquement en mesure de
demander une licence de dirigeant de
club auprès de la ligue
oui parce que je crois en plus je vais
même vous en apprendre une carte qui est
passé à côté mais la ligue été condamné
pour me l'avoir retiré et il n'avait pas
le droit de me la retirer et il ya des
juristes qui sont allés un peu cherché
voir et qui se sont pas contentés de
l'histoire du sac enterrés dans le
jardin et qui fait qu'après le conseil
d'état estimé en confirmant que je
devais avoir le droit d'avoir une
licence
alors robert louis dreyfus il voulait
pas partir maintenant ils partiraient là
je sais pas en tout cas il a dépensé
beaucoup d'argent pour peu de résultat
lyon pour peu de résultats 600 millions
vous aviez mis 60 millions et une amie
600 milliards à 10 et les murs un vrai
qu'il a gagné dans la ddas bon donc une
année ils sont généreux avec le
brouillon des eaux lui l'ami 600
millions avec ses 600 millions
finalement il n'est pas arrivé
avec 60 bah oui bah ouais c'est un
métier soit ouais mais alors est-ce que
voulez vous aider robert louis dreyfus
ah ah ah ah non regardez le club lui ça
mon son sort m'intéresse pas ce qui
m'intéresse c'est là c'est le sort de
l'om et uniquement ça alors vous votez à
marseille la tête mais domicilié ou la
non mais c'est à l'époque où j'étais
simplement conseiller régional
conseiller départemental et donc
forcément lui j'habitais marseille
j'étais député des bouches du rhône il
ya toujours électeurs à marseille ouais
alors peu de vie commence par une
incertitude en fait la première
incertitude c'est sur votre naissance
dès le début il y avait déjà des
incertitudes avec vous bah oui si vous
êtes nés sept mois après le mariage de
vos parents alors il ya deux solutions
sous la boue gêne soit vous êtes en plus
et en plus si c'est pas vrai a commencé
le 26 janvier quarante-trois voilà les
beaux parents sont mariés en juillet
donc ça fait sept mois mais pendant
quarante-trois vous êtes dansante et 43
de parents vous ont conçu si vous ont
conçu en juillet 42 vous êtes né à sept
mois prématuré je suis né v6 en faute et
avant le mariage aura dépassionner le
débat et donc l'amour cas les jours le
lundi à 10 le lundi ses ventes affichent
un bond du programme mon père je le
crois tout à fait capables d'avoir
séduit maman est comme ça fait
maintenant 60 ans qui sont mariés
ensemble on peut éventuellement leur
pardonner d'avoir fait l'amour avec deux
mois les deux mois voilà donc là moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est exactement la
formation docteur caractère comment vous
êtes devenu d'art à tapis alors quand
vous êtes né votre père était au st lô
en allemagne jeudi pour nos amis qu'on
pas connu ça si le service du travail
obligatoire si elle comprenait des
français pourrait travailler en
allemagne il ya beaucoup de jeunes
communistes de jeunes ouvriers
communistes qui avaient été emmenés en
allemagne au west et au notamment
georges marchais était parti travailler
chez messerschmidt
alors votre père jean tapie était jean
baptiste de moi tu affiches et moi je
crois que votre problème vient de là
c'est à dire que finalement bodmer
attendant les ailes d'acier tu vas
écoute le tueur leurs cartons problème
comment ces pages et même pas ton
problème parce que je vais d'excusés
dans deux minutes et tu es gentil vent a
je pense est un problème de deep moi non
mais sérieux mais voilà je vous dire
pourquoi vous le savez derrière votre
père tient le bon ouvrier le bon ouvrier
communiste le vrai quoi sur le type qui
est dur à la tâche qui veut s'élever
socialement mais à force de travail du
tout quoi pas du tout pas du tout je
pouvais arrêter la drag queen a mis l
ouvrier mon pea symbole ouvriers commun
à plein et honnête sérieux c'est pas
mi-temps politique du pays bas qui les
militants politiques jeudi que lui pour
lui le travail s'est il veut s'élever
dans la dans la hiérarchie sociale il
veut travailler pour nourrir ses membres
il fait en dix heures par semaine dans
des bernard quand il va à l'origine la
journée que le soir il va à l'école des
arts et métiers nous veillons s'élever
socialement du tout c'est pour avoir du
boulot et nourrir sa famille le vrai
problème c'est votre père c'est
quelqu'un de très rigoureux et vous
voulez que je vous dise après vous lirez
ci c'est sa voix n'a rien à voir à ça
quand vous êtes né dans un milieu qui
soit peu importe on va pas faire du
misérabilisme
il ya plein de mômes qui sont prêts
malheureux des dents milieu à bourges
par exemple c'est quand vous êtes dans
un milieu et que l'environnement de ce
milieu ne vous plaît pas oui quel que
soit le milieu en question vous vous
révoltez d'une manière d'une autre
regard plein de monde qui sont bourrés
et qui se foutent dans des mouvements
trop christian parce qu'ils supportaient
pas qu'à moi je ne supporte pas ce
milieu parce que c'est un milieu
totalement totalement soumis qui répond
à rien et de d'aucune manière à toutes
les agressions on leur fait et à partir
du jour je deviens étudiant je vais à
paris et donc sans contact de mômes qui
viennent d'ailleurs
il ya à la fois une révolte de ma part
de voir ces injustices car mon père est
intelligent il est travailleur
ibos seulement il a baigné toute sa vie
dans un milieu qui lui permet pas de
s'élever là et cette injustice là me
fait chier voilà ça rien à voir avec un
complexe d'audi prénom votre père cgc
j'ai une vraie bagarre social vous êtes
d'une famille unie vraiment rien aux
besoins d'une famille où on n'est pas
très expansif votre père est plutôt
renfermé vous êtes plutôt hâbleur plutôt
expansif justement et vous voyez votre
père travailler jour et nuit et
finalement être traitée plutôt pas très
bien et vous vous dites pour réussir il
ya sûrement des raccourcis à prendre et
ça a été et ça a été la raison de notre
opposition à votre père jour oppose
jours explique la deuxième partie la
première partie on a compris pourquoi
des gosses pour sortir de leur milieu
font des efforts un peu surhumain alors
après il est question effectivement du
parcours qui est un parcours chaotique
sur lequel de temps en temps il ya une
ligne on franchit on la franchit pas ça
c'est autre chose
ça vient de deux phénomènes bien connu
le premier c'est que on connaît personne
et on connaît pas les règles
c'est capital - joue à mon fils y fait
son site trois jours après il à l'avocat
qui a déjà pris un expert-comptable
jours après moi je connais aucune règle
aucune règle mais pas d affaire aucune
règle qui permettent à quelqu'un de
s'élever dans la société
donc je les invente et quand vous les
inventer vous êtes un parcours
initiatique vous faites des parcours bon
et des parcours mauvais ya personne pour
vous dire là c'est bien là c'est pas
bien donc vous découvrez au fur et à
mesure l'itinéraire que vous devez
prendre on est d'accord mais va donner m
le 2e etc est aussi une des raisons du
handicap c'est que vous apercevez qu'on
n'a pas envie vous changer de catégorie
vous êtes bien là où ils assurent les
accords alors mais je suis d'accord et
vous ce que je vous dis simplement c'est
que votre père lui il avait une vision
assez soumises effectivement des choses
vous vous dites c'est pas possible je
vais prendre des raccourcis au nord je
suis révolté saria l'art avec les
raccourcis et nerveux
je me suis par exemple jamais permis
jamais le car mais pas le quart 10%
vous savez tirer en le jugeant à 10 dans
un bouquin tapis à côté des grands
arnault pinault
c'est un enfant de choeur
parce que j'ai pas fait 10% bien sûr
parce que j'étais pas du même milieu
social au départ bien sûr mais je
reproche rien moi dans les raccourcis à
sept jours je ne reproche pas alors à
qu'on sait c'est qu'il est maintenant
peinture est dangereux ce qui laisserait
supposer c'est pour ça que je veux pas
laisser ce bout raccourcis souris
souffrir le mou raccourci laisserait
supposer qu'on n'hésite pas de franchir
les règles pour aller plus vite c'est
pas ça du tout mais vous dites je
connaissais pas les règles mais je leur
accorde mais c'est vrai que votre père
lui avait une vision plutôt traditionnel
de la réussite l'accumulation du travail
du temps passé et d'ailleurs vous est
jamais arrivé à l'impressionner votre
père c'est à dire qu'il a toujours été
votre réussite il a vécu comment il a
vécu comme quelque chose mais vous mais
ça va pas il était heureux à chaque fois
et moi pour le séduire j'étais content
j'étais en équipe de france juniors de
handball
il veut voir tous les matches je faisais
des concerts de viol on y venait
assister au concert ça c'est l'exact
mère vous a mis aux violences qui était
prémonitoire et ce pour but un soir
j'aime bien avant fit et je suis faible
et que tous à le défendre alors regardez
alors bon je dis qu'il faut les parents
mes parents ont eu une vertu c'est de me
donner et de m'apprendre l'essentiel et
je les en remercie dans la mesure où
c'est l'essentiel qui m'a permis de
tenir en main terminer là dessus mais
pourquoi votre père quand il a monté sa
peine dans les années 60 où chercher du
boulot pourquoi vous a jamais engagé
c'est bien parce que j'ai un problème
avec lui mais pas du tout il sait des
camions réfrigérés et il a embauché mon
frère vous êtes dans ce milieu je dis
pas que ces causes est à vous avez un
appartement au bourget non c'est au
premier étage
oui 9 voilà je dis simplement qu'à un
moment vous avez décidé travers deux
classes sociales parce que c'est une
façon de messer parent proche c'est une
façon de la volaille à vous en sortir
une vraie question d'ailleurs allé poser
souvent à ceux qui comme moi change
est-ce que c'est l'exemplarité de votre
réussite qui est positive et qui peut
donner envie à d'autres de dire c'est
possible donc on va le faire il ya eu le
cas est-ce que c'est au contraire une
manière totalement irréel et j'allais
dire insultante de faire croire des
jantes sont des imbéciles puisqu'ils le
font pas il ya eu qu'à aussi donc comme
tous les symboles et quand vous faites
des choses un peu qui sortent de
l'ordinaire
symbolique bah j'ai eu ma part de bandes
et exemple j'ai été positif et utile à
certains et j'ai été une catastrophe
pour d'autres c'est ce qui fait que dans
ce pays les gens qu'ils m'adorent et des
gens qui meurent parce que je dis
simplement c'est qu'à l'époque quand
vous allez au bord de la marne à la fin
des vacances avec votre nom mais c'était
génial vous souffriez génial à l'autre
il est dans la main visiblement qu'à un
moment vous vous dis c'est pas c'est bon
là la vraie vie c'est pas ça et pour
s'en sortir quand on est dans votre cas
il ya deux solutions il ya la boxe ou le
rock and roll et vous avez choisi la
chanson c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu
changer les eaux déjà produites ne s'est
pas deux c'est mieux c'est pas mieux
mais n'est pas mieux mais c'est pas ça à
l'itinéraire voulez pas vous sortir de
votre classe sociale est venu chercher
maintenant j'ai alors essayé de
ressortir de la soumission c'est à dire
quand je n'ose pas vous le dire parce
que je vais encore être un mauvais
exemple
mais je considère que par exemple voilà
la manière dont un représentant de la
force publique parle
un ouvrier dans sa voiture qui rit
influent rouge mais est insupportable et
maintenant il me parle plus de cette
façon et je suis content qu'ils me
parlent et j'aurais aimé qu'ils parlent
pas de cette façon là mon père qui
disait rien quand on le faisait rêver
d'accord premier boulot c'est quoi j'ai
vendu des téléviseurs
une idée géniale c'était génial parce
que c'est une époque où il y en avait
pas et donc j'avais convaincu le gars
qui étaient venus pour mandrins que s'il
les prêtait avec une antenne pendant
quelques jours il ya de grandes chances
qu'ils auraient pu envie de laisser
repartir
il m'a dit tu crois on en a mis 12 ans
un camion et sept minutes après l'es12
effet placer les gens qui sortaient de
la roseraie moi j'en veux aussi moi j'en
veux aussi et puis fit non huit jours
après avec est-ce que c'était pas déjà
une façon de piéger les beaux gosses à
je sais pas s'ils ont un téléviseur
et puis le laisser pendant huit jours en
disant attendre ont fait leur vous
disiez passable dernière l'institut de
sondage ont fait des études sur la
télévision pour qu'on vous laisse le
téléviseur pour voir ce que vous pensez
des programmes et visuelles les mecs le
vrai c'est qu'il ne peut pas l'accuser
d'être un mauvais vendeurs à ça non mais
je l'accuse
le montrent les des vendeurs qui te
vendent un truc qui te disent regarder
l'écran dans 30 ans j'y suis japon
montée quelle vision de votre vie
aujourd'hui après toutes ces aventures
pas finalement aujourd'hui je parle à
moi je ne sais pas faire un bilan à un
moment donné de la vie alors que à 48
heures près tu vois imagine je gagne mon
procès contre le lyonnais dans quinze
jours quand on se revoit je suis pas le
même que si je le perds ouais bah quand
on se revoit vous achetez tout la france
deux mois lui tout moment j'achète pas
moins vous achetez plus le nom du pot de
colle sérieusement vous avez su vous
êtes a suivi toujours les conseils de
votre père et mon père il est pas
prétentieux au point de vouloir me
donner des conseils dès lors que je
quittais le chemin qu'il avait lui-même
parcouru le conseil s'est quand même pas
abstrait c'est mon expérience me permet
de te dire attention fais pas ça mon
père dès lors que je quitte la maison je
fais des choses repères il avait notre
façon que vous de voir les choses
totalement
il est discret il est modeste il est de
il est il est réfléchi à tous les ans
tous les sens du terme
il est manuel il est capable de
fabriquer les mains n'importe quoi moi
non ouais on est on est pas pareil avant
ch qu'avant la lumière là avant de
quitter ce sujet est ce que vous dites
pas à sérieusement des fois sérieusement
corée c'est pas maintenant que vous
allez bien ça marche
mais quand vous étiez en cage comme vous
dites vous n'êtes pas l'idée fois
j'aurais mieux fait d'écouter mon père
mon père avait raison
bien mal acquis ne profite jamais ce
genre de choses qu'on se dit donc chez
jal a l'impression d'avoir mal acquis et
vous êtes jamais dit mon père avait
raison
non finalement sa vie à lui qui est
humble qui est une vie simple érables
finalement j'aurais été plus heureux si
j'avais accepté cette villa non mais
attendez je vais vous expliquer quelque
chose
il a été très heureux avec maman bref
qui depuis 60 ans et sa femme
on a fêté ensemble sont 90 m oui mais
vous vous attendiez vis à dire oui moi
ça fait 28 ans qu avec la mienne
je suis aussi heureux que lui réclame
sienne ouais malgré le parcours très
différents ouais or comme mon bonheur
conjugal compte autant que lui et que ma
vie perdre professionnel compte après et
que j'ai pas eu rater de ce côté là je
suis très heureux c'était la question
qui tue par l'abbé
[Applaudissements]
bien alors maintenant dans cette
émission le public n'est pas là que pour
faire ça il peut aussi poser des
questions qui me poser des questions
vers un tapis vous là mais ici c'est un
moyen de rencontrer des filles vous
appelez comment karine karine juste
poser une question ça vous arrive de
pleurer pour de vrai évidemment
évidemment et quand je suis allé en
prison je vous fais une confidence je
m'étais préparé puisque je les suis
trois mois al avance je m'étais vraiment
préparés parce qu'on m'avait dit fais du
training sera donc je mettais avait nagé
en bas dans ma call un lieu totalement
noire sans fenêtre sans rien et j'y
faisais des petits morceaux de 3
préventive et j'étais certain d'arriver
à subir l'épreuve sans aucun doute et
j'avais dit en partant j'avais dit ça va
se passer comme une lettre à la poste et
deux heures et demie après tu vois pas
huit mois après deux heures et demie
après quand le faux bond c'est fermé
j'ai vu mon fils qui m'a vu monter et
malheureusement lui me voyais plus et
moi à travers les grilles je voyais mon
fils et mon fils c'est push pencher sur
son volant et s'est mis à pleurer lui
est hélas j'ai fait par terre donc je
croyais avoir être capable de tenir lui
moi j'ai tenu deux heures et demie merci
vous appelez comme en amérique ou qui je
la reconnais et oui tu échappes oublié
un truc question c'est pour l'arcade et
à moi c'est pour les tee-shirts mouillés
c'est marvel ceci dit et le titien se
mouiller il ya longtemps qu'on vous l'a
fait là venant de toi je m'attendais à
mieux quand même mieux
la dernière fois que tu es venu ça a
déclenché une guerre avec madame de
fontenay
donc aujourd'hui on assiste est
contraint de laisser emmerder par un
gâteau dont plutôt que justement je vais
essayer de profiter de votre faiblesse
puisque on en parlait tout à l'heure
vous le grand charmeur le beau parleur
trois mois et demi
de prison sans femmes à six mois alors
pardon alors c'est pire justement 100
femmes est-ce que c'était pas trop dur
comme tout le monde j'ai relu avec
canal+
la prochaine coupe c'est canal+ la
chaîne des branleurs il y pense il
travaille là dessus
[Musique]
bien alors maintenant on va faire une
interview dans la peau d'un autre
[Musique]
on ne bouge pas par le jingle à avoir
commencé là didier renvoie le jingle non
parce qu attendez je vais dire un truc
avant de renvoyer de jingle je savais
pas vous avez bougé oui il ya une fille
qui me dit elle me dit est ce que chez
nous elle m'envoie un email est-ce que
chez nous aussi on doit pas bouger
pendant le jingle ben je dis oui bien
sûr un temps mais qu'est ce que c'est ça
mais alors y avait une fille vit alors y
en a une autre qui s'appelle kordan
piedi banal en didier elle maintenant je
tiens à dire ça parce qu'effectivement
d'abord à la maison ne doit pas bouger
par le jingle comme ici et elle dit j'ai
pas possible de baisers pendant tout le
monde en parle parce que toutes les
trois minutes faut lever la main pour la
promo où il faut pas bouger pendant le
jingle ok je sais c'est compliqué on y
passe des trucs comme apaisé le samedi à
ceux des trucs mais là elle comprend pas
pour s'être compliqué donc on y retourne
didier on les bouge pas pendant les
digues
[Musique]
ben voilà là c'est pas compliqué répond
pas un jour y aura des manifestations
tumeur a tiré alors va jouer un jeu donc
c'est dans la peau d'un autre c'est une
nouvelle interview dont vous êtes dans
la peau de chirac par exemple je réponds
comme il devrait répondre selon moi ou
comme je pense qu'il répondra lui avoue
répondait comme vous pensez qu'ils
répondraient lui 1
alors si je vous dis par exemple que mme
alliot-marie vous est expliqué sur la
cassette jacques chirac je vois pas
pourquoi on continue à vous embêter
c'est tout à fait vrai ouais vous pensez
que vous êtes expliqué bah oui puisque
j'ai dit j'y étais pour rien et je suis
respectueux de la fonction et je suis
président de la république sans
conneries sur cette cassette jeudi je me
suis expliqué si vous êtes de nouveau
chirac je vous dis qu à une rumeur sur
votre santé que vous êtes un peu comme
pompidou à l'époque d'alain kick
j'ai un peu grossi parce que vous prenez
de la cortisone alors c'est la cortisone
ou la bière non vous avez vu je suis
parti en vacances avec avec ma femme et
on attaque on a bouffé non mais bon là
non je crois moi c'est que il a c'est
vrai il a dû se laisser aller
ouais vous pensez que c'est la picole et
la bouffe ouais je crois bien alors
imaginez vous soyez jeu ce pas oui et je
vous dis que vous avez fait douze pages
dans gala cette semaine est ce que c'est
si malin que ça à lionel de de montrer
le luxe dans lequel vous vivez à
matignon même si son nom est blanc
écoutez on n'arrête pas de me dire que
finalement je suis très intelligent pas
chirac
ouais je suis très performant pas
schirrhein je suis travailleur pas
chirac et tous les sondages le donnent
perdant face à chirac
je demande à mes conseillers pourquoi on
by pasky libon joie à tout le monde
qu'il a une bonne grecque il sourit oui
bombe a fait moi sourire c'est plus
facile de faire des rajouts dirait
lionel que chirac qui touche le cul des
vaches et que vous vous apprêtez à
matignon dans un luxe de pala dans les
jupes robes ou ah oui je commence par ça
d'accord mais je vais finir dans le pré
des vaches d'accord ça va très bien vous
êtes de nouveau chirac vous allez tuer
comme enjeu spa avant 2002 je vais tuer
comment j'ose pas avant 2002 jacques
ça va pas être facile comment vous allez
faire je vais lui proposer de prendre
debré comme ministre et vous en sortez
bien jacques et vous lionel commence
année tu es chirac avant 2002 je vais
demander à ma garde des sceaux de
continuer de ne pas s'occuper des
affaires comme elle s'en occupe pas
maintenant voici bernard tapie pascal
rambert le sol
achat
[Applaudissements]
innovation dont al arabi
ces comédiennes faut dire que c'est un
petit peu comme ça où tu es à tous les
soirs donc ça ne change pas beaucoup
alors vous arrivez du théâtre donc du
théâtre de paris rue blanche où vous
interpréter un beau [ __ ] pour 100
représentations exceptionnelles depuis
le 30 janvier
alors c'est bourré c'est tous les soirs
bourré les gens se marrent ça va durer
plus de 100 représentations ben
apparemment on est parti pour cent
maintenant il est probable que si toutes
les conditions sont réunies pour que on
continue et que tout le monde puisse le
faire on se reverra sans représentation
exceptionnelle c'est du pipeau oui très
comment jouera pâte et légendes en fin
de compte peut-être vous allez jouer ça
les bras sans quoi alors c'est une pièce
de pierre chesnot mise en scène par jean
luc moreau ou l inverse mais bon non
c'est une pièce qui a d'ailleurs été
déjà joué par jean luc moreau en acteur
principal à la place de bernard tapie
avec des textes a dit il de bernard
tapie
vous allez y rajouter des petits trucs
qu'aucun auteur n'aurait n'aurait osé
dire en fait comme je suis un beau
[ __ ] on a ajouté aux qualités de ce
beau [ __ ] les miennes mais en tout cas
présumés tels ce qui fait qu évidemment
je deviens c'est à hurler de rire il ya
un truc génial c'est quand il arrive sur
scène donc il dit vous savez moi vous me
connaissez je déteste le mensonge et la
brune ambrée salle et les dérives
d'ailleurs explosé de rien c'est
pourquoi il ya beaucoup d'autodérision
et vous avez donc enrichi le personnage
du départ qu'ils ont fait à un coureur
un cours classique quoi un menteur mais
là vous avez fait un personnage plus
plus épais le bernard tapie telle qu'on
que les médias nous l'ont raconté
pendant des années non mais je crois
qu'il est il et il est de toute façon il
est de toute façon cynique et dans cet
exercice là il est de toute façon
menteur et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que parmi les 1000 spectateurs qui
appuient ce que ça en contient à peu
près mon sens il y en a forcément qui
sont beaucoup plus menteur que moi sur
ce sujet là puisque trompent leur femme
pas moi donc c'est sale
d'ailleurs les nerfs cette fois depuis
trente deux ans c'est à dire que bernard
tapie et avec son épouse depuis 32 ans
et qu'il ne l'a jamais trompé amèrement
malheureusement bernard je crois qu'on a
un ami m'a dit je te crois pas capable
oui c'est ça une espèce de sale au
dragueur tchatcheur mais en fait qu'ils
se trouvent toujours une bonne excuse
dans le bon prétexte dans la vie c'est
comme précis ça a toujours raison vous
vous demandez aux femmes
chaque fois que le mec trompe sa femme
il commence par expliquer pendant des
heures pourquoi il le fait est
évidemment c'est à cause d'elle elle ne
comprend pas il est malheureux al baidh
mal enfin il a toujours 1000 1500 bonnes
raisons pour expliquer à la maîtresse
qui est pas dû voilà pourquoi je trompe
pas sinon je l'aurais jamais trompé bien
attendez voilà c'est ça l'histoire
en tous les cas vous fait le clown et
vous avez l'air d'aimer ça les gens
adorent ça donc tout va bien
oui mais je reviens en enfance c'est ça
la fin la vertu de l'acteur c'est d'être
en enfance je vous donne un exemple
pendant les répétitions n'a pas d'objet
on a parlé et on sent la vente
alors si l'objet choisi pour être un
revolver c'est un cendrier et bien le
troisième jour quand on commence à
répéter où il est mon revolver et il
s'agit de retrouver cendrier qu'il
devient le revolver et si j'avais la
paille et pas question de changer par
autre chose
donc cette espèce de facultés de re de
redevenir enfant et de jouer que mon
jouet quand on est gosse qu'on fait de
chauffeurs d'autocars exemple
l'endettement et qu'on se relève qu'en
essais ça bâtit jouer au docteur lui
bypass c'est pareil tu te souviens qu'à
jouer au docteur 11 est déterminante il
jouait il fallait la température je fais
partie de mettre ça sans diplôme égal
intéressé à la question dans tous les
cas non mais à la fin de la piège quand
je dis vous prenez du plaisir mais on
dirait de funès que vous souhaitez vous
fait des grimaces vous tournez sur vous
même
c'est insensé écoutez c'est vraiment
venu au fur et à mesure que la pièce le
suscitait cas de nature on a tous une
dose de pudeur qui vous empêche de faire
à 500cc choses jusque quand même pas
courir avec la valise à la main fait
maintenant choteau tu l'état j'ai vu
très beau sur damien parce que c 'est
vrai truc rêver les enfants
alors voilà donc ce beau [ __ ] change
de femme tous les dix ans donc il ya
quatre femmes autour de lui à vous
d'abord pascal robert ce qui avait été
sa première femme conditionnelle elle
adore sa maman ouais c'est sa maman qui
[Rires]
complimente la classe d'orgue à moi je
connais l'âge de pascal regarde c'est
franchement vous êtes super en forme
vraiment voilà donc vous vous êtes la
première femme c'est dans la lah depuis
20 ans et avec vous chers agnès soral a
bougé dans l'es12 l'épousé officielle la
femme
moi je suis un voile à l'officiel
l'officiel natacha vii la maîtresse
dépressif alcoolique extraordinaire très
bien gaulée je dois dire parce qu'il
faut dire dans cette pièce est que quand
même un des grands plaisirs de la pièce
et puis rejoue un poil elle est très
déçue
teddy l'étude avec une nuisette pas très
long alors tout le monde fait ça pour
voir votre club vous savez quand même si
la voiture parce qu'elle omet pas alors
une amende n'arrive pas à la voir
ils ont un sourire et d'achat vous êtes
la maîtresse depuis dix ans 1
et puis voilà et puis le beau [ __ ]
bernard tapie vous quitte pour vous
mathilde penin dont vous êtes la petite
découverte apic nouvelles comme ça sur
laquelle il est très très chaud mais
j'entends vous voir en comprend et il
est prêt à partir avec elle donc ce que
je disais c'est quand la pièce commence
le beau [ __ ] s'apprête à tout plaquer
les trois femmes qui sont là pour vous
pour partir en australie avec vous le
problème c'est que c'est son
anniversaire il a 55 ans ouais voilà
sept jours et essaie bien choisi
choisira le pot ouais c'est pato en fait
le vrai truc c'est que je dois me tirer
en douce et mais il ya chez moi ma
valise avec tous mes pape la voilà et
donc je dis à ma fiancée julie écoute tu
m'as temps on se retrouve à l'aéroport
je vais chercher la valise est
évidemment je donne un coup de fil à ma
femme pour lui dire d'aller se coucher
je peux pas rentrer et elle m'apprend
que c'est l'anniversaire qui a une
grande fête voilà donc voilà le problème
c'est guy forget arrive à tirer la
valise au moment où il ya une fête
géante la voilà voilà
et donc évidemment problème alors
l'homme c'est malin en plus c'est que
chaque génération de fans dans la salle
se retrouve dans l'une de vos quatre
c'est là où c'est sur le plan marketing
c'est désormais parce que évidemment
tout le monde se reconnaît les hommes se
reconnaissent dans le personnage du du
beau [ __ ] saut vous en faites pas ce
que vous cheminement comme on l'a dit ça
fait 32 ans que vous êtes avec votre
épouse et vous ne l'avez jamais trompé
alors cessé du havre marche elle
ab c'est normal dans un couple y aura
toujours pour que ça dure faut qu'il y
en ait un cahill saha et ray est là
c'est dû à quoi c'est dû au fait que
secret sexuelle berlin c'est en tout cas
ça ne peut pas être ça veut pas être
l'élément qui m'aurait fait partir voix
non je crois qu'il ya d'abord une
volonté que ça dure parce que chaque
couple a des moments de crise
forcément et ces moments de crise où on
est sûrement te lire on dit bon allez on
essaie quand même ou bien et c'est tout
à fait légitime dans certains cas du
roman laisse aller et on dit autre chose
ensuite il ya les activités
professionnelles qui joue un rôle si on
a 80 % de son temps actif
résolument tourné sur son nôtres sur son
travail sur ce que l'on fait on
connaissait qu'on a moins de temps ni
lancé ni savourer ça vous dit si j'avais
pas tendre ces jeunes athlètes
je reviendrai à tromper si j'avais rien
à [ __ ] de herlies j'aurais eu dix
heures par jour a rien à faire je
l'aurais fait ensuite il ya aussi quelle
est l'évolution dans le temps des deux
personnages il ya des gens qui évolue
d'une manière ou d'une autre mais en
tout cas rarement de la même manière et
là je crois qu'on est à peu près la
chance d'évoluer par ryan maintenant
bernard à l'âge que vous avez ya plus
tellement présent vous l'a trompée elle
a même plus aucune est ce que vous
croyez que les femmes ont plus à gagner
en étant féminine que féministe 2
féminine et féministe
on a posé la question à bernard alors
moi je répondrai
non franchement
répondre est un départ ça dépend de
l'heure de la journée
alors la pièce s'appelle un beau [ __ ]
vous vous trouvez beau parce que ça ne
s'est fait ah les [ __ ] c'est admis
est beau il ya le maquillage
ouais le soir il ya un brevet pas mal
bernard sérieux c'est vrai j'ai pas un
cheveu blanc maintenant il est bien
avenue qui nie pas les cheveux si
abbaoui je vais pas sinon il serait sage
voit pas trop ya des mecs c'est qu'ils
se voient une norme
non parce qu'il y en a trop et parer à
cela il ya un moment quand c'est
quelqu'un que j'ai là c'est le moment le
plus dur est assainie blanc viguerie
ouais alors ça c'est un peu dégueulasse
moi ce que j'aime bien oui ça lui va
bien parce que tout lui va
non là bas c'est gentil mais tu prends
une chose avant d'être blanchi oui mais
ça ne marche pas parce que bondy 3 les
filles qu'est ce qu'il a de plus
séduisant lui moi je dirais cela naturel
ah ouais moi j'aime ça il y il est dir
est une nature ouais ça pêche le fait
qu'ils se laisse pas démonter
c'est plutôt une espèce de fragilité qui
se voit certains qu'ils décèlent à
certains moments et vraiment je trouve
qu'il a l'air d'un enfant virilité
évident une viralité les vies normales
as tu veux c'est réglé a vu d'autres
[Applaudissements]
et on m a dit qu est-ce que sa femme est
question n'est pas d'être toutes les
qualités réunies ça je pense que c'est
une femme qui devait à ses multiples oui
elle un cocker anglais seulement pour le
retenir oui ça va aller à l'intrus
salaires une gamine féminité elle est
très jolie
le lingala elle doit être très
intelligent
ce n'est pas non plus parce qu'elle sait
faire clc cercle à elle laisse aller
mais voilà quoi
ouais tout est sous contrôle ah ouais
c'est ça le tient par les couilles j'ai
l'impression aussi vous fassiez quoi
pascal de lui avant de le connaître
moi il m'a toujours fasciné par cette
espèce de sympathie qui peut qu'il
dégage et même je le trouve formidable
dit quelque chose on y croit mais ça je
trouve ça formidable
c'est le problème
alors pensez quoi avant mais je l'avais
rencontrée sur le louche
ah oui et j'avais donc je connaissais
d'avant et je l'avais vu jeu
bon il faisait rêver à l'époque je sais
pas à la manière dont il a été porté
comme ça au sommet je me disais c'est
bien ça fait rêver
donc je viens bon a priori avant de
rencontrer ben oui vous aussi notre chat
excellent parce que j'avais gardé de lui
certaines images des missions pendant
lesquelles il avait brillé par le passé
comme par exemple le débat le pen avec
le pen alors ça c'était quelque chose
qui m'a fait vraiment marqué va-t-il
vous pensez quoi de tapis avant de le
rencontrer
je pensais que c'était quelqu'un qui
savait tout faire ce qu'on a à son image
et pour l'instant c'est ce que je pense
toujours
et comme comédien il a des progrès à
faire comme comédien vous trouvez
l'erreur fâché mais apparemment j'arrive
sur le tout à l'heure tout à l'heure on
était dans la loge agnès m'a donné une
indication bien souvent à ce moment là
fait plutôt ça je vais faire mais c'est
vrai parce que on se voit pas mais ce
qu'on entend c'est la réaction des gens
et là on voit bien mois y avait un truc
que je voulais pas faire là vous donner
mais il y avait un moment où je servais
un alcool à une psychanalyse et la
raconte pas le coup non ma parole mais
je dis simplement ce moment là ils me
faisaient pas marrer et j'étais gêné de
le faire le soumet à manger à chaque
fois j'étais jamais faire ça j'étais
gêné car je me régale maintenant parce
que vous l'avez vu ses amours il en fait
un maximum et c'est drôle c'est à mourir
genre le réclame des tonnes ça donne pas
envie d'y aller rigolez sa peur d'être
heureux ma fille a donné du bonheur par
des membres alpa de la vie privée dans
le forez quand je sors en soirée thurman
ton public qui applaudit à chaque vague
pas moi ça dessert
je vous demande de monter voilà qui est
dit finalement cette pièce était fait
pour vous parce que j'ai retrouvé une
déclaration de vous 113 9 ans
non je ferai une déclaration de vous
lors du procès om valenciennes et vous
avez déclaré j'ai menti mais c'était de
bonne foi ouais ben là c'est ça dans la
piastre
si vous me demandez leur et je vous dis
il est 16h cibafi vous demande l'heure
et que vous lui dites 16 heures alors qu
il était 17 heures vous avez menti de
bonne foi c'est sa matière de bonne foi
oui c'est à dire vous dit quelque chose
qui est une erreur ou est une fausse
information vous l'a dit de bonne foi
alors que la dent dans ce qu'on joue je
suis de mauvaise foi et jeudi une
information fausse en sachant que les
fausses mais voilà les voilà c'est du
théâtre c'est hull a résisté voila voila
c'est la commune c'est très chouette
alors on veut bien croire à couper au
montage on veut bien croire que vous
ayez jamais menti à votre à votre femme
mais vous avez menti à d'autres gens
dans votre vie quelle est la plus belle
promesse que vous ayez faite par exemple
à vos parents sans l'avoir tenue je vais
pas mentir mais pas ouais c'est pas par
vertu ouais c'est parce que ça s'est pas
présentée et je verrai alors je n'ai pas
eu l'occasion quoi bah voilà c'est fait
oui alors c'est bien quand je parle à
des chants j'ai l'impression d'être le
seul mentor du monde
sous-entendu vous montez pas
personnellement ça ce sera coupée au
montage
bernard ça veut dire mentir bernard
qu'elle n'a plus belles promesses que
vous ayez faite aux français quand vous
étiez ministre sans l'avoir tenue
je vais vous dire d'abord celle que j'ai
fait est que j'ai tenus parce que c'est
là on n'a jamais tenu rigueur et je suis
content que natasha était et est marqué
par ce débat j'avais dit à cette
occasion là quand je suis rentré en
politique je mettrai le pen à moins de
10% est la seule élection nationale à
laquelle j'ai participé c'était les
élections européennes où le pen a fait
9,8
ouais moi j'ai fait très 14 13 cas donc
je suis content d'avoir tenu cet
engagement là et celui-là il valait
quelque chose qui tient les engagements
merci cartes de bons clients venaient de
voler vers la laure les engagements les
engagements que je n'ai pas souvenir
c'est tout ce que j'ai première d'autres
ministres ouais pour une raison simple
c'est que le temps de réaction de ce que
l'on dit par rapport à l'action c'est au
moins trois ans j'étais ministre un an
ouais bon voilà voilà là il n'y a rien
d'autre alors les promesses que vous
n'avez pas tenu vis à vis de vos
employés
aucune parce que les employés devenaient
les employés définitif que lorsque le
ménage avait malheureusement été fait
ouais qui demande la carte mais non mais
attends vous êtes vous découvrez
aujourd'hui les les horreurs des
licenciements sous-entendu il ya des
gens qui quand il se trouve dans une
structure qui marchent pas peuvent
licencier au nom de l'impératif besoin
de sauver l'entreprise et y en a
d'autres pour qui sait les bouchers
charcutiers chaque fois qu il y 16 ans y
ait quelqu'un c'était presque un bonheur
ou un plaisir de le faire alors moi je
sais pas faire je vous donner deux
exemples pourraient y compris ouais
j'suis pas à cette question
quand je reprends adidas adidas perd à
peu près deux milliards par an le
concurrent principal c'est nike qui
gagne 2 milliards par an pourquoi ils
sont plus intelligents ils sont vos
goûts nike travail avec 7000 employés
tous ces enfants chinois ou taïwanais
tous nous ont travaillé douze mille
employés tous se repère points c'est
plus cher
deux hypothèses vous laisser comme ça et
adidas est mort c'est possible ou vous
avez la charge de l'arbre et c est vous
laverez c'est en faisant ce qui a été
fait à dire des fermetures du gym qu'ont
coûtés
et quatre ou cinq mille emplois sur 12
comprends moi que les 4000 qu ont perdu
leur boulot sur les 12000 à cause de moi
considère que je suis le roi des
[ __ ] parce que quand vous leur
expliquer que c'est pour sauver
l'entreprise ils s'en foutent ils ont
perdu leur boulot
pour certains il on retrouve pas avant
trois quatre ans mais c'est comme ça je
veux dire que c'est un métier qui est ok
paris j'aurais préféré rester toute ma
vie d'artiste mais malheureusement j'ai
pas eu j'ai pas eu l'intelligence de
dire oui à lelouch quand j'avais 25 ans
c'est vrai je vous assure vraiment jeune
à l'époque oui
non mais c'est dans l'aventuré que je
regrette parce que je trouve dans ce
métier tout ce que j'aime
y'a rien de ce que je n'aime pas quand
vous regrettez pas avoir commencé plutôt
être comédien ah oui alors vraiment je
n'aurai pas à tromper tout cela laisse
la carte alors quelle est la promesse
que vous aviez fait un juge et vous avez
pas tenu ils n'ont pas eu besoin de
promesses
wayne simmonds largement vrai et on
entre et et aux supporteurs de l'om qui
est la promesse que vous leur avez fait
est qu'on a gagné la coupe d'europe on
la gagne ouais mais il ya bien que vous
avez passé quand même laquelle je sais
pas je vous demande au nom et à
mitterrand il ya des promesses que vous
lui avez fait et je n'ai pas de pauvres
malheureux non non je sais pas je me
renseigne on n'a pas du tout les
vachement vos promesses la rattrape in
norway
mine de rien bah oui mais pourquoi bina
le rayonnage c'est pas ben non c'est
pourquoi mine de rien c'est pas mine de
rien c'est oui il me débecte vous êtes
vraiment un mec incroyable vous allez
chiche chanteur d'abord d'argent mais à
l'époque où j'étais étudiant et donc
j'étais patient qui sauvait les paroles
de la chanson c'était déjà comme ça
c'est une philosophie qui étaient
contenues dans cette chance a répété
après y les paroles de la chanson c'est
crânien mais peu importe les paroles
souvent je dis n'importe quoi
si mes idées sont un peu folle vrai ou
faux ne t'en fais pas c'est bien oui
c'est toute une philosophie mais la
fedis et 1966 il fallait revoir la
philosophie des paroles des chansons de
son terrain était pas tout le monde
excuse moi je peux pas donner notre
caisse et à réussir sa vie car il sait
très bien réussir sa mue ah oui c'était
le contraire de réussir dans la vie
donc on peut tirer une phrase de tout un
palmarès
pour démontrer qu'un mec et sotchi où
cela alors vous avez été chanteur tom
d'annuaires homme d'affaires oui est ce
que c'est vrai d'arras à pic avec toutes
les entreprises que vous avez racheté
pour 1 franc symbolique vous auriez pu
vous payer un paquet de clopes
non mais le franc symbolique c'est
pareil c'est une image délirante
personnes vous donne son entreprise pour
1 franc
un si grand qu'il ya des mecs à ces cons
on arrivait et noir et les fusils
mitrailleurs on les mettait sur la tête
et bon flic bump à boîte pour 1 franc
donc c'est qu'il y avait peut-être
autour un certain nombre de choses donc
il vendait un franc mais ils ont des les
détails journée les terrains voilà à de
tous les boulots vous avez fait c'est
lequel qui rapporte le plus en argent
ouais évidemment chef d'entreprise quand
ça marche
évidemment aujourd'hui ça va
financièrement parce que vous verrez du
modèle sont gelés l'attrait du par le
fisc nikos et jusqu'au 18 mars et
tranquille 1,18 martin
c'est énorme on va voir la fête et on va
voir et j'ai un gros paquet là bernard a
tout récupéré
moi j'en tue il ya un milliard d'euros
vraiment ça vous emmerde que je récupère
non pas du tout alors là pas du tout et
franchement même franchement non mersch
pas ça dans le dans le sujet qui veut
racheter le
[Applaudissements]
et entend récupérer les sous qui
travaille chez kwassa clowns sans
frontières
si j'ai beaucoup d'argent il en est à
perdre deux membres et à ma fille de
faire un film
[Applaudissements]
moi aussi je peux payer à part des kits
en a marre d'aller on va faire on va
faire des ajouts des gens qui sont là
ont vu mon film dans sa tombe
c'est eux qui doivent alors il ya plus
être sur cette bernard vous ne manquez
beaucoup plus moi j'aimais bien quand il
vanne sinclair avec le pull en mohair
anny blatt le gros mont blanc et vous
allez l'avoir le dimanche soir c'est un
vrai bonheur pour moi il est voué bruel
c'était sympathique cette sorcière est
le seul qui a dit des choses pas
gentilles c'était moi comme un vrai elle
m'avait un peu taquiné je l'avais un peu
taquiné sur ce monde quartier ah oui
j'oubliais la vente quartier y avait le
mont blanc le but là ni bhl a dû oublier
la montre cartier
alors dites-moi à l'asservissement
maintenant on a envie d'avoir dans
bernard un an
on a envie d'avoir votre avis sur ce qui
se passe l'histoire de juppé par exemple
en pensez quoi
juppé qui se fait condamner par les
juges
et puis le présent la public qui dit que
c'est un type formidable ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'il vit ouais les
magistrats sont maintenant vraiment
devenu indépendant hier aucun doute là
dessus
aucun et par conséquent tous les
éléments qui leur donnent l'impression
qu'on leur force la main ou qu'on veut
les pousser dans un système qui dépasse
le cadre précis la loi ils deviennent
féroce moi même je les payais pas fait
le con comme ça en pensant aussi que
l'on pouvait faire le malin ou ça sert à
rien vraiment il à faire dans la sphère
celles des magistrats qui ont subi des
menaces quand ils leurs bureaux visités
ou penser que c'est possible ça vaut non
non non non il est mais je n'adore pas
ce qui était dit non les yeux dans les
yeux je me suis dit mieux vous y croyez
vous moi je vous dis je ne sais pas non
pourquoi pas j'avais envie d'être un
maire qui est des qui a eu des gens qui
essayait de tirer le jugement avant le
jugement
ça c'est plutôt dans votre boulot qu'il
faut trouver les gens capables de faire
ça dans les milieux politiques dans les
milieux politiques
ça va rien changer ils prennent le
jugement ils savent qu'il existe qu'il
est bon donc c'est pas c'est pas ça je
dis pas qu'il ya pas eu de trucs mais ça
peut pas être le fait des gens concernés
directement par ce procès ça c'est sûr
et vous trompez pas si les politiques
aujourd'hui bourg là dessus pour dire on
veut savoir ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'il s'en va qu'on a broyé vous
arrivé le loup c'est pour arriver à dire
ouais la décision n'a pas été prise
sereinement vous avez compris pourquoi
ils foncent toute la classe et pourtant
l'âge que vous fassiez pas un petit peu
de commentaires politiques de temps en
temps comme ça à la télévision oui juste
histoire de rigoler ouais parce que vous
connaissez bien les trucs à part lui et
bien par des cars
ah bah oui un peu dites moi alors le pen
en paca
j'y croyais pas une seconde non ah ouais
penser que c'est encore un épouvantail
qu on nous agite annonce comme la
dernière fois non non j'en pense que
c'est un vrai danger par et puis alors
je vous signale que tout ou toute
attitude qui consisterait à dire non
donc on fait rien ce serait criminel et
j'y crois pas franchement j'y crois pas
et je pense que muselier va le battre
ah oui c'est d'ailleurs parce que vous
êtes plus pote avec muselier donc été
invités par terre avant plus qu'avec
vauzelle qui a beaucoup plu et
socialistes pas parce que j'ai fait
beaucoup à vos elle qui m'a beaucoup
fait chier alors que j'ai rien fait à
muselier qu'elle est sympa etc et voilà
à quoi ça tient
donc voila moi je m'en fous le reste ça
pas l'intérêt mais voilà il est comme ça
oui il est un peu comme ça tu peux
compter sur lui quand tu as besoin de
rien alors qu'eva joly était sympa
et je vais bien me marrer un piston avec
lille en a marre bien un sarkozy
président en tout cas c'est quand même
pas une hypothèse dénuées de tout
fondement
apparemment quand on voit les sondages
ça a l'air d'être bien parti pour lui
j'ai l'impression - oui sarkozy j'avais
pas de ce bord là dois je regarde ça
avec mes enfin d'après ce que voit il ya
des il ya des sondages qui ont l'air de
le placer très largement devant tout le
monde
ça vous le savez où vous le craignez
sarkozy faisait peur qu'une fois au
pouvoir ils tiennent un petit peu trop
autoritaire il ya personne qui peut
devenir troupe autoritaire dans ce pays
qui est ingérable
ah oui bien sûr on veut tout changer
toujours médaille vous bougez un truc
tout le monde gueule mais je vais faire
le malin je sais très bien que personne
peut être autoritaire fait un peu comme
ça bon pas longtemps comme avec les
gosses de maintenant vous les voit la
paille a put il ya plus de papas et
mamans autoritaire y en a mais bon cela
ils sont vite émis par le juge du coin
car on ne peut le prendre
bien alors dites moi alors on va
terminer sur votre âge parce que dans la
pièce de nous raconter pendant toute la
soirée à la wii je suis dans le 43ème
savez que vous avez quoi pour rester
conserver comme ça que selongey une
belle poussée de la grille j'apporte ma
fourche je vois pas ça se serait à wimby
vais pas vous filmez je ne boit pas une
goutte d'alcool et je suis libre et je
fais un tout petit peu l'amour et sa
fatigue des femmes enceintes et vieillir
prématurément
tu dois le savoir
chacun des taudis
très enfants bernardin juvénile secret
quand même être un peu tôt tour de
france quitte fil des trucs
toute façon vu que ça secret j'ai pas
vous le dire un jour je vous le dirai
sans arrêt les produits un truc
ah oui et puis je vous dirai si vous
voulez les mêmes c'est cher bernard
tapie va se recycler dans l'anti âge
c'est ça voilà en tout cas ça marche
75 regarde 75 ans
[Musique]
non
voilà bernard d'abord merci d'être là
vous n'avez rien le nombre et vous êtes
là par solidarité pour tout le monde en
parle parce que c'est l'avant dernière
émission
[Applaudissements]
ils arrivent à vendre
mais celui-ci il a quand même il a quand
même demandé trente mille euros les dix
pages
je signale que personne ne me les a
donnés sans dans le jardin non mais
c'est vrai franchement ça fait vraiment
plaisir parce que parce que c'est c'est
une émission qui va manquer beau c'est
donc je suis content de venir avec vous
deux à l'occasion d'un de ces dernières
années voilà merci
alors bien sûr on va parler politique on
va commencer avec avec le foot avec le
mondial avec les bleus
syfy
lors des rares vous expliquer comment
cette métamorphose des bleus dans le
match contre l'espagne il ya plein de
raisons mais on va essayer de sortir les
essentiels la première et la plus
importante c'est le changement total de
psychologie et de motivation quand on
rencontre le togo la corée même la
suisse
les français ont beau se dire et se le
dise il faut gagner on va mettre tout
notre coeur on va mettre toute notre
énergie
ils font appel à ce qu'on appelle la
motivation volontaires celles qui
dépendent sa volonté
quand tu rends compte l'espagne et qu'
il s'agit de passer un cap et surtout de
remettre les pendules à l'heure là c'est
tu fais appel à la motivation
inconsciente
celle qui le fait courir le 100 mètres
parce que ton gosse se noie 1
la vraie différence à ses claques qui
font ils font appel à des ressources que
seule la volonté ne peut pas de données
or quand on sait qu'un être humain
utilise à peine la moitié de ses
potentialités
un quart sur un marche comme ça tu
obtiens letru bon alors ensuite
l'espagne eux ont vécu le contraire on
aura mis la tête comme ça c'est les
futurs champions du monde ce qui fait
que malgré l'ouverture du score qui
aurait pu leur permettre de temporiser
un peu de jouer les malades restez
derrière évasion continue on continue et
ils nous ont donné des boulevards
derrière que les français ont bien su
exploiter ses énormes masses énormes
parce que on a vu ce que ça a généré
chez les gens c'est l'imaginaire
c est une belle démonstration de ce que
les gens sont capables de faire lorsqu
on leur offre un événement qui verra un
bill à thouars les familles devraient en
tout les français sont derrière tu es
incroyable je sais pas si tu as eue dans
les rues par tours 1 c'était une c'est
un bonheur exprimé sans limite et qu'on
voit pas dans l'autre dans d'autres
formes d'existence ce que le sport et en
particulier le football
moi je vois jamais des gens qui se
connaissent pas dans la rue qui
s'embrassent et c'est la grande certains
quartiers
c'est les boîtes privées oui
alors voilà cette émission est
enregistré exceptionnellement avant
france brésil puisque on est jeudi soit
la voilà donc tu vas me donner un
pronostic et le mage vient de finir
ouais c'est horrible objectivement je ne
fais juste la réputation bernard parce
que je ne peux que te dire là ce qui va
se passer un sûrement un et te dire je
souhaite tellement c'est tellement envie
qu'on gagne que je te fais pas de
pronostics je te fais que mon souhait
oui oui j'ai vraiment la trouille
j'ai vraiment peur parce que réellement
sur le papier autant il n'ya pas une
autre équipe
franchement y'a pas une autre équipe qui
nous est supérieure dit bien sur le
papier
sur le papier le brésil nous est
supérieur alors maintenant est ce que
cette espèce de confiance convient de
prendre cette espèce de 2,2 volonté de
ne rien avoir à perdre parce que
maintenant ils ont fait l'essentiel on
est en quart de finale contre lundi l'un
celui qui gagnera sera dur à battre le
fait que l'arbitré espagnol conneries
pour nous un difficile difficile
forcément y rêver devant gérer les
espagnols nous met à l arbitre espagnol
moi je pense que y'aura forcément à dire
sur l'arbitrage
un malheureux temps ces couacs en
montant la merde parce que c'est le
coucher du soleil c'est quoi l'oiseau
derrière j'ai d un merle
mais c'est génial jantes à la tombée des
jours cgt jure que non
je ne connais pas les saisons la nature
tout ça tu connais pas ta mère la kia
merde j'en ai dans mon jardin ici peu d
jeanne moreau il peut très vite fait
tous les jours et moi je finis la la la
la
on est devenus potes vous pensez quoi
des condamnations dans le procès des
comptes de l'om par tapie et je veux
qu'on pense la même chose que quand elle
s'adressait à moi
elles ont strictement aucun sens tu peux
pas condamner robert louis dreyfus pour
abus de bien social dans son club dans
lequel il a mis 130 millions d'euros
je veux dire faut être un peu
schizophrène
tu peut l'accuser plein de choses
éventuellement médard fait des contrats
bidons d'avoir arnaqué j'avais l'urssaf
que les joueurs et est pris chez sur les
impôts
je suppose qu'il doit y avoir dans le
dossier des choses mais ils n'ont pas
retenu là dessus donc ça veut dire qu'il
était coupable de rien d'autre que ça et
là c'est du délire
on peut pas reprocher à un mec d'avoir
été puisque le délit d'abus de bien
c'est d'avoir porté tort à son entrepôt
en gros en gros tu portant à ton
entreprise quand tu mets 150 millions
d'euros dans les caisses
un drôle de mazaugues donc ça tient pas
debout alors à suite si on veut parler
des systèmes qui tourne autour du foot
en france je parle tous les clubs ont
recours aux mêmes arnaque qui consiste à
pouvoir faire des salaires
concurrentiels avec les étrangers qui
payent moins d'impôts
voilà tout le problème est là quand un
joueur est sur le point de venir en
angleterre en espagne en italie ou en
france
il choisit un autre pays que le nôtre
parce qu'il est plus taxé alors
puisqu'on parlait tout à l'heure ça va
vous intéresser
on parlait tout à l'heure des pronostics
je vais vous dire pourquoi la france est
devenue un petit pays de football
l'angleterre tous les joueurs de
l'équipe anglaise joue en angleterre
mais qui dit à sauve bk l'italie tous
les joueurs déclin italienne journe
italie l'espagne tous les joueurs
l'espagne joue en espagne également tous
les joueurs allemands jouent en
allemagne les français trois joueurs
français jouent en france 1 on a rejoint
le peloton des pays sous développés
c'est qu'à cause des impôts ils sont
vides et je lui en sais faire que ça et
c'est globalement c'est un fossé les
contrôles c'est dur ça c'est un pays qui
devient pu tellement pressurisée que les
gens ont envie d'aller ailleurs et ce
qui se passe dans le football ne vous
faites pas d'illusions
c'est comme ça pour les artistes qui
peuvent partir ailleurs c'est comme ça
pour tous les autres sportifs de haut
niveau c'est comme ça pour les grands
chercheurs c'est comme ça pour les
grands ingénieurs et ça va finir par
être comme ça partout pour tout le monde
tu as vu personne peut être y aura six
il y aura ceux qui veulent un attendent
des autres leur salut personnel
mais est ce que cette crise de confiance
envers l'équipe de france finalement ne
traduit pas ne reflète pas une crise de
confiance du pays en lui même les
français sont très bizarre parce que il
rien sondage sur la croyance le bonheur
et c'est à qui m'a vachement épater ses
c'est ça dans le challenge début de
l'année question êtes vous plutôt
heureux plutôt malheureux 80 2 % des
gens plutôt heureux 4 deuxième question
pensez vous que les français sont plutôt
heureux
malheureux il pense que 82% des français
sont mal c'est dément fait tourner en
schizophrénie total ça veut dire que
toutes les nouvelles toutes les infos
qu'ils sont ce qu'elles sont on va pas
reprocher aux journaux télévisés dire
que il ya tant de morts par le sida qu
il ya le tsunami etc
n'empêche que leurs impressions à eux
c'est de vivre au milieu d'une tempête
incroyable qui fait que tout le monde
doit être dans une merde noire m on doit
souffrir et pas nous mais c'est pas vrai
je veux dire c'est un des gros problèmes
qui rend ce pays très compliqué à gérer
c'est pour ça que c'est un pays où il ya
un taux de suicide très important c'est
le plus gros consommateurs
d'antidépresseurs au monde la france est
un ouais c'est vrai que au moment dé des
trente glorieuses
on a eu un modèle social très développé
qui était vraiment bien bien installés
qui était basé sur le partage sur le
fait que tout le monde doit profiter au
moins en ce qui concerne l'éducation la
santé la justice
des progrès qui sont faits et puis ils
ont pris pour beaucoup l'habitude d'être
un peu ce qu'on ne saurai zain peut
assister et quand ils se sentent plus
dans cette situation de sécurité
beaucoup perdre les pédales
on est aussi un des pays où le divorce
fait le plus de ravages et crée des
situations dramatiques quand un couple
sans moyens
divorcé il ya des mecs qui couchent dans
la bagnole parce que ils ont de quoi
payer un appartement pas deux évidemment
heureusement on laisse la femme dans
l'appartement avec les enfants et le mec
il a plein en juillet dont donc en
dehors de la souffrance affective
il ya une souffrance matériel terrible
mais il y avait un sondage d'enlever
l'observateur dont on parle d ici la
semaine dernière déjà moi ki moon qui
m'étonne complètement ces aides vous
favorable ou non à l'économie de marché
alors en chine ses 74 % des chinois sont
favorables à la commune marché aux états
unis ses 71 % dans les grands pays
européens c'est 65 66 % et en france et
34% tandis que la france est très en
avance et elle a compris que le
capitalisme s'étaient pas bien et lé
post capitaliste ou au contraire elle
est très en retard
il ya un problème on avait d'abord il
est possible qu'il existe un système
beaucoup plus efficace plus généreux qui
rend les gens plus heureux qu'on le
connaît pas un puisque pour l'instant on
a mis en opposition le marxisme a généré
un socialiste puis mme social-démocratie
et puis la loi du marché bon encore une
fois la loi du marché pour les gens
c'est l'abandon d'une certaine sécurité
et d'une certaine protection sa place je
recommande t il plus protégés forcément
les français sont les plus opposés à le
demeurer
ensuite et à l'interprétation qu'on
serait dans le moule la loi du marché
pour beaucoup la loi du marché c'est la
loi de la jungle et il faut reconnaître
que par certains égards c'est un peu
vrai
alors est-ce que le français est plus
malin plus impertinent plus rigoureux
pour exiger davantage c'est un peu tout
ça maintenant il faut que ces
français-là se disent que s'il existe
une autre technique une autre méthode
c'est pas la france qui pourra l'imposé
seul parce qu'elle fait 2 % du monde la
france donc dans un monde qui est
entièrement soumis à la loi du marché
on est obligé de l'adopter c'est du
baratin alors on a des mecs j'entends
besancenot j'entends tous les ans c'est
bien c'est c'est rafraîchissant les
entendent dénoncer
ils font quoi que dalle la france est un
peu le village d'astérix aujourd'hui non
c'est impossible à vue qui l'a dit les
patrons faut tous les virer
on les remplacera ouais par quoi par
d'autres patrons 1 qui auront une
nouvelle hiérarchie toute la société
basée sur une ira
si que tu es tu mets 150 mecs sur une
plage tu laisses un an et demi tu
reviens il ya un patron il ya deux
adjoints puis elle connard en bas plus
rien du tout parce qu'il sait pas quoi
faire et la société doit être bien
organisé parce que celui qui est en bas
il a le droit aussi de vivre deux pas de
piétiner d'être protégé qu'on lui pique
pas son dû pour lui baissent pas sa
femme il a le droit
alors c'est là où la société doit être
organisé pour faire face à la limite aux
aux inégalités de la hiérarchie mirarchi
elle existe dans les pays socialistes y
avait une hiérarchie dans les pays
capitalistes une hiérarchie la france
est un pays qui s'accommode mal des
hiérarchies apeas et égalitariste la
france bat on lui a fait sa conception
comme ça simple et logique alors en tous
les cas tout ça donne aux prochaines
élections présidentielles
une importance considérable un oui
falloir faire attention au programme là
parce qu'après abc moi je pense
franchement qu'on n'est pas dans la
situation dramatique qu'on raconte
on n'est pas bien et là il va falloir
être très prudent je crois que c'est une
réaction là sont les dernières où on a
le droit de se tromper alors vous vous
avez pas revenir en politique pourtant
vous êtes éligibles depuis trois ans
mais vous avez parvenir
est ce que vous avez peur vous dit quand
je voulais devenir maire de marseille on
a trouvé 100 mille francs dans un jardin
pour m'envoyer en prison l'affairé om va
si je suis candidat à la présidentielle
on va mettre 100 kilos de cocaïne dans
mon coffre peut-être passant parce que
l'on coop ne tient pas mais quelques
kilos n'aurait c'est une matière de dire
que on
me veut pas tout le monde est finalement
bombay dont elles ont ils veulent rester
entre eux c'est un métier de faire de la
politique
les professionnels al politiques ont
toujours une distance à l'égard de ceux
qui viennent pas de rang mais c'est vrai
de kouchner c'est vrai de borloo c'est
vrai de tapis c'est vrai de tous ceux
qui à un moment donné ont eu envie de
franchir le pas est-ce que c'est
légitime
quelque part oui quelque part louis
parce que on n'a pas donné en tout cas
de gages sur la réalité de nos
convictions notre programmation etc
par conséquent on peut croire que on est
capable de séduire sur des éléments
d'appréciation qui justifie pas le vote
c'est pour ça que les électeurs font une
grande distinction entre la côte d'amour
avec des sondages extraordinaire un
kouchner le vote
1 le vote c'est une opinion la côte
d'amour c'est une humeur ça nous ramène
d'ailleurs à faire attention aux
sondages
alors vous allez pas revenir en
politique bernard mais vous allez
intervenir d'abord au nom des trois
millions de gens qui ont voté pour vous
ça là c'est parce que du sondage la
belle humeur d'un cd bulletin blanc dans
l'urne
et puis peut-être aussi au nom du parti
radical de gauche non c'est là que je
suis parti parce que c'est la
philosophie radicale entre parenthèses
qui est peu développée on a l'impression
qu'il existe plus de 2 mais le
radicalisme c'est justement ces faux
souvenirs c'est gambetta m'emmenait
série c mendès france et l'école
publique obligatoire elle apaise
séparation de l'église et de l'état
parce je veux dire c'est des choses
encore quand le dal le radicalisme qui
privilégie l'homme plutôt que les cistes
qui met l'homme au centre de ses
préoccupations de ces débats qui
considère qu' un état une nation n'est
forte que par l'addition de ces valeurs
individuelles
elle reconnaît donc la valeur
individuelle comme un élément
d'appréciation mais à condition que les
intérêts individuels soient compatibles
avec l'intérêt collectif normale en
termes un peu plus simple ça veut dire
quoi
chacun se démerde chacun essaie d'être
le meilleur on doit pas envisager une
égalité par le bas rhin
et face à la scolarité donc à
l'apprentissage face à la santé face à
la justice
on doit tous égaux le chanceux le
malchanceux l'intelligent le conte tout
le monde c'est la règle et c'est la
république c'est la réponse est ce que
la belle a abaissé sa alors en 2007 vous
croyez vous à un match
sarko ségo pour l'instant il il est plus
que probable way est vrai que les mecs
comme le hand comme fabius comme strauss
kahn fait quinze ans les mecs qui sont
là qui rament voudrait qu'ils vont
laisser ségolène royal leur pic elle non
seulement je crois que pour les cm et
alors là pour le coup je comprends rien
à la stratégie du parti socialiste rien
c'est le contraire justement de ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure du radicalisme
l'élection présidentielle c'est un
candidat ou une candidate qui se
présente d'or les français qui fait une
proposition qui dit voilà la société tel
que je l'imaginé et qui s'entoure des
gens pour la mettre en place le parti
socialiste commence à te dire voilà le
programme on se met tous d'accord sur un
programme dont on est tous d'accord pour
dire la même chose et après comme un
casting comme un film un film tu fais le
scénario et après tu as le metteur en
scène commence à choisir les acteurs
mais c'est de la folie
cheikh candidats socialistes à la
candidature devrait faire son programme
passer devant les militants pour que les
militants c'est vraiment un homme et un
programme et non pas pour un homme ou
une femme sur un même programme
c'est ça qui les amène d'abord à dire
n'importe quoi t'as vu c'est golem et
toujours à 1000m suis dit qu'une phrase
à des méchas les y en a pas un qui pense
pareil
or les sons ségolène royal vendre son
programme celui auquel elle croît 1
si les militants socialistes en veulent
pas ils peuvent préférer strauss kahn
qui ne manque pas de qualités qui
manquent pas d'idées ou phallus qui
manque pas de qualités qui manquent pas
d'idées et après par la loi normale de
respecter le vote des militants tout le
monde se met derrière le candidat et son
programme plutôt que ça alors qu'à
ségolène qui est pour on sert un peu la
vis
le parti socialiste qui est là on sert
pas la vis
ta ségolène qui est pour le mariage nom
déconne pas les comptes de marjah tu
comprends plus rien c'est du délire
sigolène vous la connaissez bien ouais
elle est sympa près elle parle de blair
mais faut pas vous faire d'illusions
elle est socialiste
ah oui oui oui oui vrai de vrai alors
choqué msawbaa les îles et make any
sarkozy faisait de copains vers là non
plus non non je les aime bien
ouais je le connais on se connaît est
lui aussi cinq ans dit la redoutable
mais lui il est dans une configuration
qui est plus facile parce que l'ump
c'est devenu son parti il est à la fois
prescripteurs des idées de son parti et
récepteurs de ce que le son parti
propose autrement dit il va nous faire
une programmation qui en main de ce
qu'ils ressentent et des hommes qui vont
le soutenir pour le faire donc là il est
plus à l'aise pour aller devant les
électeurs que quelqu'un qui va défendre
un programme qui est pas le sien donc je
dirais que normalement on a plus de
chance alors c'est peut-être une bonne
ou mauvaise chose
chaque français fera ce qu'il veut mais
vous n'avez plus de chances de voir
sarkozy faire ce qui va dire qu'il va
faire un cahier socialiste que les
socialistes parce que lui il a toutefois
laissé son programme et a vu que
j'espère revient le pays cette semaine
oui j'ai vu dans la même semaine on a
quand même eu les idents qui a annoncé
qui dira s'il est candidat au 1er
trimestre 2007 mais et jospin qui nous
dit officiellement ce qui l'a pas arrêté
nous dire fou quand même dire que ça
fait un an qu'ils nous dit un autre
témoin ou givet et si vous m'appelez je
vais y aller ouais donc on vous rendez
compte on va peut-être assistait une un
autre france-brésil quoi à la limite ça
va être de nouveau le combat des chefs
qui mélangent aux princes crois qu'il se
met hors jeu en faisant ça ils seraient
pas hors jeu en étant candidat il se met
hors jeu en annonçant qui peut l'être si
on va le chercher parce qu'il aurait pu
très bien
ne pas annoncer qu'il était candidat
avant qu'on le demande
et là ils avaient une légitimité quelque
part pourquoi
d'abord parce que il croit pas un
instant que ségolène royal est capable
il dit pas qu'elle va pas gagner
il estime tout le monde sait qui la
considère pas capable d'être prêt lyon
me république
deuxièmement il pense que les
communistes les verts les extrêmes
gauche etc
il est à peu près le seul à pouvoir
faire la gauche plurielle espèce de raie
gauche plurielle donc s'il avait été
effectivement demandé sans qu'ils lisent
c'était crédible un nom mais là ils leur
demandent qu'on l'appelle alors qu'on le
demande pas je crois qu'il s'est
disqualifiée tu crois que les gens lui
en veulent en plus de cette barre en
2002 qua non ils lui en veulent pas de
cette barre en 2002 il a eu une attitude
au contraire honorable j'allais dire
digne minimum que tous les politiques
devraient avoir moi le jour où j'ai été
mis hors la politique pour les ans vous
savez je me suis mise même si maintenant
je suis éligible
je considère qu'on peut pas dire ben
attia je suis fini je reviens il a été
porteur d'un échec terrible il
il en a souffert terriblement il a eu le
seul comportement digne que tous les
hommes politiques n'auraient pas en
vouloir pour ça allons il a été le
contraire ils ont plein ramadan sidi
attendait finalement je vais peut-être
me routel danois là ça sent un peu le
faisant des tapis vous serez candidat de
toute façon dont le film de fabien
onteniente et qui s'appelle le candidat
justement j adorais somec j'ai rencontré
un il m'a dit qu'est ce tu prêt page
d'une pièce comment s'appelle le
candidat il m'a dit non tu fais un film
avec moi 1 il est vraiment génial donc
on va faire un film ensemble à la
rentrée la wii et j'ai bien aimé son
approche il à la jane bonne idée alors
j'ai déclaré j'ai connu la vie avec
beaucoup d'argent je la connais
maintenant sans je préfère la vie avec
et ben ça vous étonne pas tout est mieux
c'est vachement mieux c'est vachement
mieux parce que les gens essaient de
mettre en opposition l'argent une bonne
heure par exemple
évidemment si tu me dis tu préfères
riches ou en bonne santé
ça suppose que tu es riche et malade oui
je préférais pauvres en bonne santé mais
t'es pas obligé d'être malade parce que
tu es riche un groupe met donc en bonne
santé richir bonne santé pauvres
c'est nul en bonne santé riche mais
c'est tout mieux arrêter décoller la
gare à la gare non mais vous le balaur
et vous non mais c'est mieux d'avoir de
l'argent dit me voir je vous dit
maintenant je connais la vie sans argent
ça veut dire quoi et bien d'avoir un
salaire qui correspond à un salaire de
cadre
on n'est pas plus non puisque tout le
reste c'est rigoler ah non mais quoi que
vous gagnez maintenant ça ouais et
courbis vous trouvez qu'il était trop
lourdement condamnés en lan tu as eu
leur mi deux ans de prison
ouais c'est pour faire quoi et puis la
récupérer le sursis d'avant il a
récupéré 18 mois j'ai dû faire deux
choses vachement grave quand même pour
moi rami n'en prenant pas mis ces
entreprises qu'on donne à un type qui
violent courant que j'essaie donc il a
dû faire des trucs terribles et je crois
pas qu'il est gênant terrible vous
l'avez bien long oui j'aime beaucoup
verlhac à dire vers une ère division
bernard vous pensez à quoi en ce moment
là j'ai bien ouais on t'envoie bapi
devoir vous je suis tue bien voilà quand
vous regardez le matin dans la glace
vous dites quoi bernard le seul moment
où je me regarde dans la glace et moment
où je me rase et franchement je me parle
pas dans ce moment-là ça l'est aussi
dans la journée d'accord dans la journée
savary champagnole tous je vous dis
allez vas-y mon gars ne pourront pas un
exemple vous auriez mai ressemblait à
qui quand vous étiez petit bernard bas
comme tout le monde ça dépend de l'âge à
quel âge pas vers 12 ans là quand on
commence à 11 ans 12 ans mel ferrer mais
elle fait rêver parce qu'ils sautaient
audrey hepburn j'étais plus belle espèce
comprend me suis belle histoire d'amour
bah c'est la seule avec ma femme ça fait
32 dans quel but rails c'est beau 32
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les gens ont
gardé un peu le sens du couple quoi sert
première difficulté ils divorcent quoi
oui mais il ya des couples c'est
vraiment un coup de bol parce que tu
vois bien il ya des gens pleins de bonne
volonté on va pas se forcer quoi c'est
pas quelque chose qui te permet vouloir
la vérité c'est faux quand même voilà il
faut dire je veux réussir et il ya des
passages difficiles et souvent on
s'aperçoit que si tu sur mon fils il en
y mettant un peu du sien obtus repas
voilà nous on a été vraiment vachement
bien pendant vingt ans sans aucun
problème puis on a commencé à rentrer
dans l'habitude et la tune a eu sauf un
et sophie nous a redonné un coup
incroyable parce qu'on s'est retrouvés
d'un euro par an avec les problèmes d'un
enfant en bas âge et c est là tout va
bien
ah ouais super est ce que vous seriez
prêt à tout quitter pour le grand
tellement sûr demain dans la rue vous
tombez sur une base s mais fou d'amour
jeu l'avenir de ma femme j'ai tout fait
j'ai arrêté de bosser
1 c'est à dire quand on s'est connus on
a arrêté l'un et l'autre de bosser on a
vécu ce aux économies et on a vécu neuf
mois on n'a rien fait d'autre rien
d'autre que manger dormir et tagada
tsoin après et puis tu me lis qu'on
bosse quand est ce que vous allez
pleurer pour la dernière fois vers là
quand j'ai vu dans ma loge avait pas les
30000 euros promis les a mis dans un
trou c'est un jeu télé locale j'y étais
pas je suis allé on l'a fait football tu
m'en veux pas me changer rien quoi en
vous si vous aviez une baguette magique
ma date de naissance ouais ah ouais
qu'est ce que vous pourriez dire de plus
négatif sur vous et tu crois pas qu'il
en a été si dit comme ça sans moi j'ai
été gâté quand même on m'a retiré on m'a
privé mes droits civiques
on m'a privé mais droit parental on m'a
interdit de sport on m'a interdit de
politique comme interdits d'affaires on
m'a dit 'maintenant refais toi rhin
l'authentic qu'ils ont cru que j'allais
d'ailleurs par me refaire jamais il ya
un moment où vous êtes dit je vais
jamais y arriver à me refaire après
plusieurs fois et justement si vous
deviez était à refaire qu'est-ce que
vous changeriez le sexe ah oui bah oui
j'ai connu mec maintenant j'aimerai
connaitre pas
tu as envie de te faire attraper dont
vous seriez vous soyez un peu épais
c'est pour ça que je te dise à qui
avez-vous le plus envie d'épater dans la
vie ah c'est un truc que j'ai jamais
aimé ça j'ai jamais aimé épaté en berne
ap
je veux donner deux exemples j'avais un
beau bateau jamais personne a pu monter
dessus voir une photo de l'intérieur de
mon bateau on n'était jamais ailleurs
que loin il a été acheté par une femme
on a le bonheur chambre à coucher là
elle a mangé un les dîners le projet
raneem sur la rn6 à épater c'est-à-dire
non moi je ne sais pas c'est pas j'aime
bien
j'aime bien surprendre j'aime bien être
et mais j'aime bien là mais j'aime pas
épaté alors deuxième exemple le bateau
se fut le premier c'est quoi le deuxième
exemple mon à ma maison
d'accord personne est rentré faire des
photos dans le même si le chien est
huitième il n'a pas fait de photos il a
piqué les meubles qu'est ce que vous
feriez si vous restez 24 heures à vivre
à crédit
je crois que je réglerai quelques
comptes quand même quand même vrai juste
avant de parler daiwa il y en a
quelques-uns qui sont pas soldés encore
il ya encore deux trois bourre pif dans
l'air et ouais il ya 2-3 une tournée à
faire est-ce que vous avez déjà pensé au
suicide
oui une fois en prison non non non
c'était dehors et grâce à la halle à à
la présence d'esprit ma femme ça c'est
que ça s'est passé
qu'est ce que la vie vous a appris d'un
répit qui le pire n'est jamais certain
comment aimeriez-vous mourir enterré
incinérés un vrai qu'on l'enterré vivant
comment du centre à non mais sagement
complète
j'ai pas peur de ça du tout chez voyant
j'ai pas fait trop de mal
mais contrairement à ce qu'on a dit a
pas tellement de gens qui ont souffert
et donc à la fin du parcours je pense
qu'ils mirent allait bien il était temps
que tu arrives c'est patrick r non je me
suis coupé le doigt avant de venir
commente été coupée le douar et j'ai
voulu remettre une appli qui était pas
droites et entend bien aller plus en
prison vous repasser par la case départ
et vous toucherez sans se rendre compte
pas millions d'euros alors tu en es où
justement et que c'était à faire des 135
millions là aujourd'hui je viens
d'apprendre que la cour de cassation qui
devait se prononcer en juillet début
juillet
le premier président a fait un
communiqué pour dire que c'était
reporter en séance plénière au début
octobre pour choisir tu as gagné en
première instance et a gagné en appel
l'ag en cassation si en cassation tu
gagnes tu as gagné tu récupères le
pognon et si tu perds c'est rejugé
entièrement depuis le début non non
c'est là ça repasse devant une chambre
d'appel alors on appelle revient à
l'appel ouais mais ça fera là donc je ça
va faire trois mois de plus donc ça fera
12 ans et 6 mois que c'est les jours
s'en fiche c'est sans fin 12 ans et sim
dans la sortie c 135 ans c'est trop dur
et j'ai pas mais tient dans la poche
rien toi c'est gras dans dans les poches
de l'état
et maintenant
vu les noms qu'il amène à mâcher
l'arabie
[Applaudissements]
derrière cabine bon soir alors c'est
bien bernard les plus veinards de la
bande 147 millions d'euros
le 30 septembre 2005 la cour d'appel de
paris a rendu justice pour avoir
dissimulé la vérité sur les conditions
d'achat et de revente d'adidas
la banque devra payer 147 millions
d'euros à bernard tapie mais la juge
[Applaudissements]
voir devenir comme ça là c'est un peu le
comte de monte cristo quoi c'est à dire
que vous revenez vous avez raison
schwarzy abibac albert bons ballons il a
fallu attendre neuf ans oui alors ce qui
est extraordinaire c'est que votre
version de la terre en fête vous l'aviez
données bernard tapie dans un livre
publié en 1998 chez plon qui s'appelle
librement et que vous ressortez
aujourd'hui avec un avant-propos mais
sans avoir rien changer du livre sauf
qu'à l'époque personne s'ils étaient
vraiment intéressés vous en avez vendu
100 milles mais voyait pas été salée pas
retourner l'opinion disant voilà non
mais parce que c'était pas le sens de
l'histoire et qu'à cette époque n'avait
pas envie d'entendre une autre version
que celle qui était connue de tous c'est
à dire c'est un brigand c'est un voyou
il n'a pas de morale c est quand on est
dans cette situation là c'est c'est très
compliqué d'arriver à renverser la
tendance
et même si on l'écrit et même si on fait
des émissions de télévision
dans ces circonstances là je me souviens
avoir fait une émission avec un type que
tech est un bon animateur télé lui et
non c'était celui qui remplaçait anne
sinclair sur ses fils de michel field on
a eu vraiment pris notre temps et
j'avais expliqué des trucs quoi j'avais
sorti les papiers j'avais dit regardez
ça fait depuis 96 que la première
sanction est déjà tombé et à la fin de
l'émission la fédé est et les gens
disaient ah c'est un escroc mais il est
fort il est bon c'est ça il est vraiment
mon voyous mais il est vachement bon
alors dans cet avant propos que vous
avez rajouté pour la rue publication de
ce livre d'art tapis vous dit évidemment
un
j'ai gagné deux je veux quand même
rendre justice à la justice de mon pays
c'est toujours évidemment une bonne
nouvelle quand on apprend que au delà de
la morale et des envies d'aller dans le
goût du pain nombre des magistrats
regarde le droit et la haine ne se
contente que d'appliquer le droit c'est
vrai vous dites dans cet avant propos
que c'est le contribuable qui va payer
deux euros chacun mais que vous avez
fait gagné tellement d'argent dans nos
maisons nos confrères je dis qu'il va
pas payer
je vais qu'il a la chance de ne pas
avoir un froid à sortir sur cette
affaire dans la mesure où un tapis de
francs c'est une partie du bénéfice
non mais c'est une partie du bénéfice
qu'ils ont encaissés oui c'est bien ce
que je vous dis pas et deuxièmement ça
va même pas coûté le franc question car
ça a été provisionnée depuis très
longtemps
ouais vous voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est un c'est de l'argent qu'ils ont
gagné en trop donc ils me rendent un
petit bout met en garde deux fois plus
que moi dans la rue et contribuables ils
ont gagné 600 millions d'euros le crédit
voilà voilà donc les braves alors vous
en voulez bernard tapie à ceux qui vous
en ruine est bien entendu à ce que comme
vous dites qu'ils ont fabriqué votre
faillite mais aussi au relais d'opinion
qui n'ont pas tenu compte du contenu du
livre lors de sa parution
et quand on lit votre avant-propos vous
rappeler que dit 1996 le tribunal de
commerce avait jugé qu'il y avait un
préjudice financier considérable et
ensuite depuis dix ans en fait c'est le
crédit lyonnais qui a fait traîner
devant les avocats ont fait leur boulot
en faisant ce que beaucoup de gens font
c'est à dire de gagner du temps et c'est
un des problèmes de la justice française
s'est très souvent les procédures sont
longues
elles sont plus que contradictoires
elles permettent de faire des sursis à
statuer de faire des expertises en fait
tout le monde sait que les grandes
affaires judiciaires en france en
matière civile ses 10 ans ceci étant ils
nous ont fait perdre 10 ans de votre vie
quand même oui alors on perd pas mais en
tout cas ils m'ont fait vivre une vie
n'aurait pas été la même mais bon j'ai
vécu des moments un peu un peu compliqué
voilà c'est ce que vous avez rajouté
dans le la nouvelle version du livre
c'est l'avant propos
pour le reste vous l'avez laissé tel
quel vous ne l'avez pas le corriger mais
c'est vrai que quand on lit ce livre
maintenant depuis votre victoire contre
le crédit lyonnais
ça prend un nouveau relief alors ça
commence quand vous êtes condamné à huit
mois ferme dans la sphère au mba vous
allez en prison et vous raconter c'est
assez poignant d'ailleurs vous racontez
votre départ je voulais absolument
donner enfin j'avais envie de lutter
quoi j'avais envie de leur dire vous
n'allez pas en plus vous faire le
plaisir de me faire du mal dont je
m'étais entraîné pendant presque quinze
jours je mettais foutu dans la cave
huit heures par jour et je m'étais dit
tu apprendras être solitaire et c'est
donc pas femme est partie elle a pas
voulu vivre mon arrestation je lui dis
vas la partie avec les enfants sports
d'hiver et seul stéphane est resté avec
moi et j'étais absolument convaincu en
lui disant tu verras il va rien
m'arriver ne fais pas de bile une belle
chance quand j'arrive dans la cour du
palais de justice qui va mettre dans le
four bon stéphane m'avait suivi avec son
scooter et
au moment où je monte dans le faux bond
lui voit pas que je le vois il s'écroule
le port et là tu vois ton greuze qui est
en larmes
donc en fait j'ai tenu une demi-heure
quoi ouais avant que ce soit dur alors
vous mais à la prison de la santé régime
d'isolement et vous décidez la de vous
nourrir de l'ordinaire de ne pas faire
d'achats supplémentaires pas de
somnifères pas tranquillisants pas
d'anti dépresseurs et vous décidez de
vous évader par la pensée il ya un truc
assez joli c'est que tous les soirs à
22h vous avez rendez vous avec votre
femme est ce que par contre dommage
c'est qu'on n'a jamais réussi à avoir le
même rendez vous on s'invente est un
rendez vous près à poil sur un lit
tranquille les yeux fermés c'est vrai
que c'est le seul moment où on voit pas
où on est quand on a plus de lumière et
puis point de repère là en fait on
essayé de communiquer tous à être se
donner des rendez vous réguliers mais en
fait c'étaient des rendez vous manqués
puisque on a essayé de savoir si on
pensait la même chose mais c'est jamais
arrivé ouais alors pour échapper à cette
prison vous décidé d'écrire ce livre
et puis bientôt votre père est victime
dans l'infarctus alors vous demandez
être transféré à marseille aux baumettes
finalement vous vous retrouvez à la
prison de luynes à près
d'aix-en-provence et là l'isolément et
hérite cirque est même plus de fenêtres
à ce moment là je suis en plein moment
de l'été à 40 qui fait 40 à 50 dans les
cellules c'est des trucs qui font 9
mètres carrés mais séparément - vers je
suis pas en train de tout les gens qui
sont dans des prisons dans ces
conditions-là souffre pareil et le
solaire apparent c'est celui qui passe
sous la porte
et donc on est jugé pas inventé tout le
monde on est dans cet état on est
appelés avant de partir en train de
respirer sous la porte
puisqu'il n'y a pas de fenêtre qu'on a
le lit c'est un truc en béton qui est
scellée dans le sud ouest c'est
vachement dur par rapport aux phocéens
s'étaient mais là vous dites là vous
dites quand même j'ai sérieuses envies
de suicide quand même à vous mais c'est
pratiquement tout le temps dans les
débuts comme sas s'est d'ailleurs
incroyable une lutte entre votre
conscience qui lui veut absolument
cesser de vous battre et votre
inconscient qui vous donne l'énergie
pour le faire et vous remarquerez que
tous les suicides dans les prisons sont
d'abord interviennent très vite à peine
dans les premières semaines et pas
souvent sur des condamnés de longues
peines autrement dit ça n'a rien à voir
avec la projection d'une vie sans espoir
alors vous raconter dans ce bouquin
toute votre vie quoi la faire au mba le
crédit lyonnais vander mazda look enfin
toutes vos affaires
et puis votre engagement politique il
vous dit que en fait mon engagement
politique a sonné le glas de mon bonheur
c'est à dire que jusque là tout vous
réussit c'est un moment vous raconterai
mitterrand qui voulaient pied à l'étrier
et en 92 quand bérégovoy vous propose
d'être ministre de la ville en fait vous
ne savez pas mais j'ai très content vous
à ce moment là je suis je saute sur mon
lit je suis heureux comme un enfant
et parce que c'était venu d'où je venais
je venais du même endroit que bérégovoy
d'ailleurs été ça qui était
symboliquement intéressant à l'époque il
existe encore des ministres qui étaient
des ministres de famille d'ouvriers ça
existe depuis maintenant et c'est
dommage et bérégovoy qui m'appellent
pour être ministre ça a été pour moi un
choc énorme
au point que j'ai accepté tout balancer
s'arrêter toutes les affaires sans
essayé de calculer si c'est à dire nous
vers la soul man 2 vous prend pour un
gros malin enfin c'est quand même un peu
excusez moi je suis malin non mais vous
êtes très malin mais enfin tout
abandonner c'est à dire abandonner
toutes vos affaires
arrivé en job de ministre à non non
c'est pas pour un job de ministre
attendait ça faisait cinq ans que
j'étais député j'ai été député européen
depuis trois ans et je mesurais malgré
tous les bonheurs que j'avais pu
rencontrer dans les eaux de vie que ce
soit footballeur que ce soit dans le
cinéma 31 j'avais mesuré que c'était jeu
c'était gratifiant
c'était c'était vraiment l'activité
humaine qui me correspondait le mieux
j'en avais une envie folle alors qu' à
aucun moment j'ai des projets que ça
risque est ce que ce n'est pas manquer
de cynisme à ce moment là vous auriez dû
vous dire bon bérégovoy et me propose
d'être ministre vais quand même pas
mettre tous mes oeufs dans le même
panier
parce que c'est ce que vous avez fait
finalement oui mais parce que la banque
était moi ma banque depuis 17 ans ils
étaient mes associés et administrateur
dans mon conseil d'administration
c'étaient des amis étaient bien qu'ils
passent leurs vacances avec moi alors
j'explique à nos amis téléspectateurs
vouvry de racheté adidas et de devenir
ministre vous devez vous en séparer
parce qu'effectivement il va y avoir des
licenciements chez adidas 5,6 1000
licenciements à prévoir quand on est
ministre de la ville c'est mauvais genre
donc vous vous séparez d'adidas toutes
les affaires voilà vous donner un mandat
de vente au crédit lyonnais
je voudrais dire est très très important
mairie qu'on le vise aujourd'hui il
s'agit pas du crédit lyonnais
d'aujourd'hui nurse affirmé je pense que
c'est important vont le salit de
l'ancien k-way et à ce moment là le
crédit lyonnais se revend à lui-même a
dit date donc je sache pas le prix c'est
incroyable qu'ils revendent en fait à
des sociétés offshore qui leur
appartiennent et ensuite seulement ils
le rendent à robert louis-dreyfus du
doubs voilà comment ça s'est passé
exactement
donc vous comment avez vous su cette
histoire c'est comment avoir reçu
quelques 10 lyonnais où les devants
directement à robert louis dreyfus avait
vendu d'abord et les sociétés offshore
et un coup de chance incroyable j'avais
une juge d'instruction qui était
acharnée contre moi comme elle l'a été
d'ailleurs à chaque fois qu'elle avait
une cible c'est madame joly qui est par
ailleurs une femme peu importe à la
sellette
j'étais pas son pote et donc elle
cherchait par tous les moyens comment
est-ce qu'il a pas un compte à
l'étranger commencent à peu et elle a
fait des perquisitions partout dans tous
les lieux où je risquais d'avoir une
trace me concernant et aux lieux aux
lyonnais a pris tous mes comptes les
gestion des comptes les comptes rendus
de mes comptes et en prenant tout elle a
pris les bordereaux qui étaient les
actes de portage des sociétés offshore
c'est à dire on découvre la secoue qui a
dès que les sociétés qui ont acheté
c'est en fait les sociétés qui faisaient
portage c'est elle qui ta peau et la vie
pendant des mois qui tête et gagné 167
millions d'euros la vie et moeurs la fia
l'a par exemple et je vais vous dire
pourquoi la mairie sur l'a3 la lui dire
justement maintenant que le jugement est
rendu
c'est qu'à l'époque on lui a dit mais
madame vous rendez compte que ça serait
peut-être intéressant maintenant qu'on
sait au moins qu'est ce qu'est devenu
cet argent puisqu'il est parti au lof
sort elle m'a dit je suis pas saisit de
la sphère
oui c'est à dire que la fesci et b dumas
pendant des plombes pour savoir qui lui
avait jeté ses pompages de la 20 mille
balles mehal a jamais voulu savoir qui
avait sorti l'argent des offshore qui se
mourait o'byrne il est bien allé là ce
soir
[Applaudissements]
alors effectivement à partir de là il
yal'affaire des comptes de l'om la
fraude fiscale should fossé enfin pour
vous c'est la bérézina connaître jusqu'à
jusqu'à 80 13 a un prix et algériens pas
une condamnation et après 94 traité
voler tout je fais des faux tableaux je
fais je fais des déménagements des
détournements d'actifs des escroqueries
l'abus de confiance
une banqueroute enfin en un an et demi
ouais ils m'ont fait un un palmarès
unique en france
vous êtes devenu l'homme à abattre parce
que effectivement vous êtes devenus
ministres et votre carrière politique
semblait s'ouvrir sous de bons auspices
ils ont eu peur que vous présentiez au
aux élections de l'an passé c'était plus
simple c'est que en france en politique
pour mourir il faut être condamnée par
les deux côtés ouais si vous êtes d'un
côté l'autre vos protège comme ils se
tiennent un peu il ya pas de risque
là j'étais j'ai pas eu de chance parce
que je venais de faut bien le dire
éliminer rocardien politique alors qu'il
était heureux mais nous aviez fait 12,5
est lui très sain cas c'était un +12 9
et 13 80 et la liste socialiste était
vraiment que des gens formidables yahvé
kouchner rien et langues
il y avait zéro car ça c'était toute la
banque quoi donc ils sont animés ce mec
qui vient tout seul nous faire
pratiquement le score il faut pas qu'ils
nous fassent paillot présidentielle avec
jose pas et la droite voulait garder
marseille ou blanc était candidat donc
la droite voulait m'éliminer pour pages
soit maire de marseille et la gauche
pour pas que je fasse chier j'ose pas
hélas comme tu as les deux c'est à dire
pile tu as perdu face à la paire du
journal à la pièce elle tombe sur la
tête et c'est pas facile
en d'autres temps en d'autres temps je
pense que le problème aurait été réglé
d'une manière différente je suis même
certain
il vous aurait mis une balle dans la
peau vous pensez voir je pense que la
plaint qu'on finit éliminés dans des
conditions plus dramatique que la mienne
dans ces ados robert boulin un donc
doigt c'est comme ça personne n'a obligé
de le faire j'ai commis l'imprudence de
le faire et voilà on m'y reprendra plus
vous avez 60 bien à lui
eh bien là vient la phase aller lille et
caen bien se tenir
monte cristo il est coriace ouais alors
donc ça acteurs on a vu le business et
revenir dans les affaires ont fini aulas
à montréjeau heureux de tracteurs
vraiment je fais du théâtre tous les ans
à paris l'année d'après en province je
fais 4 5 valence par an je suis
vachement heureux et j'ai découvert une
activité avec le théâtre qui est unique
ah oui moi je vous ai vu sur scène c'est
chiant mais j'ai pu croire beau [ __ ]
et c'était drôle à être heureux autant
que ça alors c'est ça il fait ça paraît
que nous est alors le business non le
sport et les revenir dans le sport oui
parce que ça c'est un truc l'om je
reprenais om nom lorraine marche bien
vous êtes sur lci dans onze matches mais
ça c'est marrant j'ai un barème assez
des postes dès que vous n'êtes pas là
l'émission allah vous les avez accroché
une drogue dure là bah ouais je dis vous
n'êtes pas dans l'émission elle
persistait des journalistes assez
compétent matraque tout le monde et qui
crache tout le monde les joueurs les
clubs les dirigeants et tout est là moi
je suis arrivé pour les casser un peu
pour leur dire attendez vous dit des
conneries et tout donc les gens se
marrent évidemment comment ça va bernard
et pascal praud très bien vous n'y est
pas mis un pain aujourd'hui mais on va
très bien depuis la cicatrise et depuis
vous êtes réconcilier avec pascal praud
oui un bourrage avait été fâché on
repense pas méchant rythme normal
on va te souhaite un bourre-pif entre
amis enfin franchement y'a pas de quoi
faire car c'est vrai bernard que vous
allez reprendre le red star pour faire
une deuxième équipe parisienne c'est ce
que j'aimerais faire à ce serait bien
parce que c'est une vraie équipe de
banlieue elle et elle a une histoire
extraordinaire ce live à saint-ouen
par conséquent pas loin du stade de
france le jour on sera en première
division mais enfin ça y'a rien de fait
mais moi j'aimerais travailler avec eux
voilà ça c'est bien mais pas forcément
en étant le t1
alors voilà et la politique alors non je
regarde agir bien non non non non non
sérieusement sérieusement je vais
revenir chez mes potes radicaux parce
que c'est vraiment des gens qui m'ont
soufflé tout le temps mais pour faire
comme chacun de ceux qui s'intéressent à
la politique sans être élu ça reste un
pays en france où je le faisais avant
avant je faisais toutes les émissions
politiques je n'étais pas élu quand je
me suis fait le pen je n'étais pas élu
non et j'ai été invité pour parler avec
lui pas gentiment d'ailleurs est bon on
a un problème parce que moi donc on
n'est pas obligé d'être élu pour faire
de la police la corps dans simplement
les clients les bons clients sont part à
son de son art ouais parce que votre
femme elle a dit toute façon si je fais
de la politique je divorce
oui bah oui elle a quand même beaucoup
souffert
oui elle était très courageuse un canton
en canton relève le lin c'est une
grossesse comme ça ouais ouais je
comprends vous la trompiez pas en fait
bah voila je suis ton beau et malin hein
le relais il a trouvé nord mais il a
trouvé quand même je suis désolé et
solide à l courageuse quand même un
dominique là parce que dans web
bon alors là maintenant on va passer
quand même
et encore quand même quelques nuages
noirs bernard on va les évoquer vous
avez des ennemis vous le savez le cdr
qui est l'organisme liquide acteurs des
actifs de l'ancien crédit lyonnais lui
veulent en cassation a le cdr c'est à
dire ils disent nos mouvements nous on
n'accepte pas la décision du tribunal
donner à bernard tapie 147 millions
d'euros
nous on veut aller en cassation il dit
ça fait neuf ans finalement peut essayer
de gagner de trois ans de plus d'accord
en gros c'est la société de défaisance
du cailleret c'est ça elle a pris tous
les actifs et comme son nom l'indiqué ça
doit être quelque chose qu'à une vie
extrêmement courte pour iris que ça doit
trancher les litiges ça doit vendre nos
actifs et vivent à l'abri trancher les
litiges vers hébreu ils sont encore là
ils dépensent par parents des centaines
de millions d'euros d'avocats a mis
d'accord qui sont toujours les mêmes a
ouais d'accord et les avocats passent
leur temps à expliquer ce coup ci aurait
gagné ouais on est sûr de notre coup
d'essai cultive life ils ont pendant
huit ans expliqué qu'ils allaient gagner
ça va coûter 500 millions d'euros aux
français
ouais et aujourd'hui centre à nous
expliquer la en cassation on va gagner
ouais alors bon ils peuvent durer encore
donné dans cet organisme là il ya votre
ami charles de courson
il est maintenant lien oui c'est un
député un député ump de la marne je
crois et il vous aime pas non et
pourquoi pas je dois pas être son genre
lui il ya les fils du peuple c'est ça
non non je sais pas du tout je ne
connais pas bon il se trouvait là a mené
un combat qu'il poursuit avec toute sa
haine etc
moi je lui rends pas je ne le connais
pas par contre ce qui est inquiétant
problèmes concernant ce personnage en
gros pour que les gens sachent c'est un
doctrinaire moraliste lui veulent en
cassation
faire l'amour atteint avant le procès
souvenez vous il y avait une grande
émission sur je sais plus si c'est la
cie sous la iii on l'appelle les
émission d'investigation sur le procès
aucun avocat
aucun et aucune partie ni moi ni adidas
avons accepté d'aller à cette émission
alors qu'on était un mois du délibéré
lui oui ouais faire ça le dérange pas
d'aller fracassé de parler d'un sujet
alors que normalement c'est totalement
interdit
le tout pour essayer de forcer la main
aux magistrats et puis là depuis que le
jugement et il continue lui commente le
jura il est incroyable parce que quand
on dit bernard tapie pourrait revenir en
politique ce qui apparemment n'est pas
le cas lui il est déjà prévu il dit mais
bernard tapie pour la présidentielle par
exemple il trouvera jamais 500
signatures à la présidentielle par tapie
ne trouvera jamais 500 signatures riches
il a dit par exemple c'est que si on
fait pas 5% l'objet de rembourser les
frais de campagne qui sont payés par le
gouvernement
il y met si tapie ne fait pas 5% qui va
payer les frais de campagne série
pensent déjà que j'allais à la
présidentielle et que vous n'aurez pas
les 500 signatures et que vous ne ferez
pas 5%
je crois qu'il est digne d'être dans
l'écurie de bayrou en fait c'est ça la
hausse
il est dans l'écurie de bayrou est oui
autre problème par rapport à l'avenir de
leur tapis et la cena l'avant avec notre
ami course on sait les affaires
pendantes c'est à dire la fraude fiscale
pour commencer alors vous on vous dit
voilà va falloir payer encore vous dire
que j'ai été déjà il est génial
j'ai été tellement sévèrement jugés non
mais ça ce sont toutes les affaires
pénales qui étaient suspendus au
résultat de la sphère civile très
conséquent maintenant que la sphère
civile est connu les magistrats ont
entre leurs mains les éléments
d'évaluation qui n'avaient pas je dois
dire que grâce
a2 au parquet au parquet général on a
réussi à interrompre un cycle infernal
sans ça on aurait pu rester encore cinq
ans comme sahara est une question qui
m'intéresse c'est pendant toute cette
période là disons des dix dernières
années pendant que vous attendiez le
procès en appel finalement quels sont
les gens qui nous ont pas laissé tomber
tous mes potes genre kouchner s'est
guère à jacques lang le lait
borloo borloo bien sûr ouais je me suis
pas gouré sur mes copains
alors non ta vie comme vous êtes le roi
de la chat vous allez finir mes phrases
je donnais des vues comme des lapins
en ce moment je sais pas ce que j'aimais
ça se présente pas mal c'est bien un
truc que je sais pas faire c'est faire
semblant
la seule différence entre le théâtre et
la politique c'est quand on tue au
théâtre c'est pour faire rire bravo
[Applaudissements]
ce qui manque un chirac par rapport à
mitterrand c'est jacques séguéla le seul
truc que j'ai jamais pu m'offrir avec
l'argent c'est le crédit lyonnais
je me serai remboursé plutôt pas
pourvoir est en général je plus aux
femmes qui ont le goût du risque
c'est vrai au moins franchement
maintenant je peux te dire l'émission
que je faisais sur tf1 je regrette de
l'avoir arrêté à y aller comme ça une
bonne tête mais montre en dehors je
tirais l'âge pour pour t'apprendre que
tu fais pas la différence entre l'acier
l'olympique lyonnais avait des prêts des
barrois en quoi on en acier champions
non mais il a été sympa avec moi parce
qu'un jour j'ai gardé ça et je les
gardais on est on faisait les missions
sur canal j la slap juste avant que j'y
aille
un bis j'ai un truc pour toi tu le
regardes la corde du sera partie civile
car la poche quand je regarde ce que
c'est c'était car du monopoly vous êtes
libéré de prison est bien
[Applaudissements]
quand la piste est habilité -tout cermex
son micro en direct à la télévision
thierry cette incroyable depuis la
dernière fois ce que tu as tu sens plus
heureux mais il n'y a même pas de
comparaison c'est le soir qui fait ça
c'est qu'ils sont vraiment porte bien le
deuil de sens que ça y est quoi voilà le
jour mais 60 ans je me suis dit tout
marche à et tout marche
ah ouais t'as besoin de viagra du cialis
c'est là dedans le bon choix et
franchement c'était l'été au ballon ma
place je suis sûr que dans les boîtes et
alors j'en étais plus normal ça aurait
fait plus normal merde
[Applaudissements]
le combat le plus dur que j'ai eu à
mener c'est une chanson de brassens qui
dit les gens n'aiment pas que l'on suive
pas le même chemin que ouais c'est un
peu ce contre seuls à accepter de renwez
réputation c'est ce qu'ils veulent pas
qu'on soit différent quoi ils sont
nombreux aujourd'hui ce qui me rend le
plus fier c'est mes enfants les quatre
c'est marrant malgré tout ce que j'ai
vécu je continue à croire que qu'il faut
toujours y croire
des fois je me dis si seulement j'avais
pas alors ça je me le dis jamais jamais
jamais pas une fois je me suis dit ah si
j'avais su mais c'est ce que j'aime dans
la vie j'ai pas de rétroviseur mais par
contre je garde c'est ce qui fait que je
garde jamais de mauvais souvenirs des
gens qui m'ont fait chier je promets à
celui qui me traitent encore dans à 10 m
1 pas sont des souvenirs d'un truc chez
moi j'aimerais que ce soir j'ai fait des
écoles pour les jeunes qui étaient sans
boulot ouais et on à la sortie près de
10000 sans rien demander à personne et
il y en a près de 10000 dans la nature
ouais qui rue belle carrière grâce à mme
parmi tous les salopards qui m'ont trahi
je n'oublierai jamais bien que mes potes
n'étaient pas dans le lot
ça fait leur entrée à tangi demander ça
il ya quelques années tu t'es tu t'es
battu avec quelqu'un un peu comme avec
pascal praud
il est là ça t'embête de le voir moi je
n'ai sympa je m'en fous tu vas lui
serrer la main
ben ça dépend qui sait michaël youn
[Applaudissements]
des deux gérants c'est l'appel du qatar
veut entrer parce que c'est quoi
l'histoire c'est que c'était sûr c'était
sur skyrock sûr que bernard s'en
souvient même pas au fait il doit
peut-être même pas se souvenir lors
c'est moi je vois tu gagnes impasse si
messi faut dire regarde ça tu reviens
pas je te jure que si bernard était
invité pour parler du de l'excellent
site internet de son fils des ans et il
y avait un auditeur qui lui a posé une
question sur sur le match benfica
marseille à l'époque où il y avait eu la
main de vata tu étais sorti du match en
disant je me suis fait avoir une fois
voilà je vois tu recommences tu vois
l'auditeur n'a pas dit exactement la
phrase que vous aviez dit à l'époque
voilà l'auditeur a dit vous à gérer vos
primes allemand que l'on peut faire
voilà et donc rien à voir avec ce que
j'ai mais quel con alors l'auditeur dit
si vous avez 10 à bernard bernard dit
non je n'ai pas dit ça le devient si ça
non car on mange du bois ok on va couper
la poire en deux bernard de toute façon
que vous l'ayez dit ou pas c'est pareil
vous avez fait 8 mois de prison c'est
quand même pas pour rien c'est ça que je
faisais et c'est là que vous êtes énervé
un peu quoi c'était un peu une phrase de
petit con mais ça marche donc bernard
jette son casque on était en différé
bernard 715,6 dit quoi je viens en ami
on pose des questions à la con comme ça
il va dans le bureau du directeur et dit
non je suis pas d'accord comment ça se
fait qu'on traite comme ça et moi je les
loire un petit peu désolé je dis bon
c'est ce qu'on va faire berner comme on
n'est pas en direct on va ré enregistrer
la fin et c'est là que vous m'avez dit
non on va parler ans jusqu'à la fin ce
qu'on va faire c'est que je vais te
casser la gueule
et là j'en ai certainement là et là
bernard avec c'est très très belle
palucher ces très grosses paluches
mam est une bonne petite claque dans la
gueule une claque et moi je te liés
c'est pareil en bleu il accompagne bien
le mouvement et à ce moment là mon
directeur d'antenne m'a demandé de
présenter mes excuses que j'ai refusé de
faire et défaire et le fun était fâché
non mais tu vois parfois il ya des
choses qui t'énerve parce que le mec il
peut te prendre en défaut entre citant
une de tes phrases il faut que tu
l'acceptent mais pas qui tu cite une
phrase que t'as pas dit oui mais
pourquoi pourquoi il claque un l'époque
je n'en sais pas ce que je veux c'est
une rapide lorsque tu joues le malin oui
c'est je voulais faire le malin tu avais
envie de te faire pousser et puis en
plus je suis pas sur la question tu
l'avais pas fait poser exprès non et
voilà il c'est là que vous avez tant
parce qu'il y en a des mecs qui font ça
tu sais que derrière compass a fait
repasser des textos en va des écrans le
pape doit pas exister mais qui font des
phrases qui existe pas ou qui reçoivent
des sms qu'ils inventent quand j'allais
me fasse un bisou
parce qu'à l'époque à l'époque faut
comprendre que j'avais un sport il y
avait un sport casser du tapis voilà
c'est que les mecs c'est à celui qui
arrive est le mieux morrell alors il y
en a pas braquer une analyse sur toi
choix des bons gars comme je te dire
allez ça va les mecs
lorsque tu vas faire tu vas lire son
livre ah oui à la paix
bien entendu librement ses déliés
non monsieur
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
attention attention c'est pour nous tous
un pain moisi vert c'est quoi ça c'est
impossible c'est quoi photo mary trouver
un point commun et jean marie le pen
alors un point commun j'ai pris l'avion
pour aller à strasbourg attend d'accord
oui j'ai pris l'avion pour aller à face
vous une fois par semaine pendant que
j'étais député européen rebecca et là je
suis vous devez donner tout l'argent
vous avez sur vous à une oeuvre
caritative
j'ai pas une cuma
mais je vais me rattraper demain
suffisent je suis parmi les eaux du lac
ont bien été donnée pour le cachemire
parce que franchement cachemire non mais
je te jure que pour toi
[Applaudissements]
la mesure
[Musique]
non
contre la montre à l'est il pas la leur
et celle là à voir là s'ils étaient tous
à un souvenir d'un écran 10 lionel sens
et lydien
[Musique]